Philip Bigwix, [musique]
bonsoir.
Bonsoir.
Nous vous recevons pour une chaîne
internet qui s'appelle Syerview. Nous
sommes en direct. On aurait dû faire un
débat avec Laurent Alexandre, mais
Laurent Alexandre a eu un empêchement
personnel. Euh, il va nous proposer
d'autres dates. Donc, on va réorganiser
cette interview et ce débat
ultérieurement au mois de juin si
possible. Euh, est-ce que vous pouvez
vous présenter succintement ? Oui, ben
je suis donc Philippe Biwix, je suis
ingénieur, j'ai 47 ans et à mes heures
perdues de manière assez intersticielle,
je j'écris des essais. Euh je fais
quelques conférences de ci de là sur le
la question technologique au sens large
et notamment la question des ressources
et des questions environnementales.
Alors Laurent Alexandre n'est pas là,
c'est dommage.
On le salue peut-être qu'il regarde la
vidéo pour se préparer pour le mois de
juin dans son train là. Et euh est-ce
que Laurent Alexandre a un raisonnement
qui vous pose problème dans sa capacité
à projeter ce raisonnement sur notre
société à court et moyen terme ?
Alors bon, c'est un petit peu difficile
parce qu'il est pas là ce soir, mais
c'est vrai que j'ai du coup j'ai révisé
un peu Laurent Alexandre ces derniers
jours et il y a un certain nombre de
voilà d'écrit et de de positionnements
qui qui me posent d'énormes problèmes en
tant que que modeste ingénieur.
Alors, j'ai dû réviser par exemple mon
échelle de Kardachf. Alors bon, c'est
petit rappel.
Voilà. Alors, c'est l'affiche Wikipédia
de très modestement Nicolas Cardf. Donc
c'est quelqu'un qui en fait travaillait
sur les programmes de type CTI en fait
recherche de d'intelligence
extraterrestre et qui a un peu théorisé
des échelles de consommation d'énergie
qui permettrai éventuellement de
découvrir des civilisations galactiques
très avancées. Alors l'échelle de
Kardachev c'est niveau 1, c'est on
consomme toute la l'énergie disponible
sur une planète. Niveau 2, on consomme
toute l'énergie disponible
sur pour correspondant à l'étoile autour
de laquelle la planète orbite. Et puis
niveau 3, c'est on consomme la galaxie,
l'énergie d'une galaxie. Alors ça paraît
un peu un peu stupide. Alors pourquoi
est-ce que je parle de cette échelle de
Kardachev ? Parce que Laurent Alexandre
a a commis la semaine dernière, je crois
ou la semaine précédente
une tribune sur le fait que l'humanité
allait consommer de plus en plus
d'énergie. le fait est qu'on consomme
effectivement de plus en plus d'énergie
et qu'on allait finir par atteindre un
niveau de de civilisation galactique de
niveau 2, je crois dans consommation de
d'une étoile complète. Alors, comment
est-ce qu'on fait ça de manière assez
concrète ?
Alors, aujourd'hui, on est à peu près à
terw de terra, pardon, de de puissance
au niveau au niveau de la consommation
de l'humanité.
Euh bon, peu importe ce que ça donne
comme comme chiffre de consommation de
annuelle, mais c'est à peu près un 10
mm, on va dire pour faire simple de
l'énergie qui serait disponible de ce
qu'on reçoit du soleil. Donc on est même
pas on est à 1 du niveau 1. Mais alors
avec 2 % de croissance en fait tout ça
ça va très vite. C'estàd alors 2 %
du niveau 2
non un 10 milliè du niveau 1. Donc on
est on est à un 10 milliè c'est
d'ailleurs ce que les partisans de des
énergies renouvelables. L'énergie
solaire elle est non seulement
disponible pour des centaines de
millions, des milliards d'années jusqu'à
ce que le soleil a un petit problème
mais on en consomme une une très très
petite partie en terme de du du flux
incident qui arrive effectivement sur la
planète. Donc non, c'est un 10 du
niveau, hein. Alors, si on fait 2 % de
croissance, euh j'ai fait tourner mes
petits tableaux Excel, assez simple, euh
par an, c'est à peu près ce qu'on fait
sur la consommation électrique depuis
euh quelques décennies, euh entre 1 2 %
un peu plus par an. En fait, ça va très
vite hein. C'est le principe des
exponentiels. Donc en 37 ans, on double
la consommation quand on fait plus 2 %
par an. Ça marche pareil avec le livret
de Caisse d'épargne. Et puis on fait x 7
en un siècle et puis en 1000 ans, on
fait x 400 millions.
Et pour faire 10 milliards x 10
milliards, c'est-à-dire passer de
l'échelle de niveau 1 au niveau 2 et
l'échelle niveau 2 au niveau 3, il faut
juste 1600 ans je crois. Enfin, pour
faire le calcul. Alors donc du coup ça
veut bien dire qu'effectivement en
suivant la logique de de Laurent
Alexandre ou des des corps nuucopiens,
on peut dire des gens qui pensent qu'on
va faire toujours plus, effectivement à
2 % de croissance par an, il faudra
réussir dans il nous reste à peu près 3
à 400 ans euh pour consommer
l'intégralité de l'énergie disponible
sur la planète. Donc ce qui nous sépare
à peu près de de Descartes et de
Montagne, voilà, c'est ce qui nous reste
pour cramer l'ensemble de l'énergie
disponible à l'échelle planétaire. Faut
passer ensuite à l'énergie du soleil et
voilà. Alors bon, ça m'a laissé un peu
pantoi parce que effectivement je suis
pas astrophysicien mais enfin j'ai quand
même un peu de mal encore à comprendre
comment est-ce qu'on va d'abord pourquoi
est-ce qu'il faudrait se préoccuper d'un
problème dans 4 milliards d'années
c'estàd la galaxie d'Andromède qui
paraît-il va venir cogner la Voie
lactée. C'est vrai que ça me fait pas
tellement frémir mais il y a des papiers
scientifiques assez assez [grognement]
rigolo et étranges qui traînent. Par
exemple, il y a un monsieur qui
s'appelle Dan Hooper qui a commis un un
papier fin 2018
sur le fait que dans 100 milliards
d'années, on allait avoir 100 milliards,
on allait avoir un problème parce qu'en
fait à cause de l'expansion de
l'univers, il y aurait plus assez
d'étoiles dans la zone correspondant au
nuages de Magélan je sais pas quoi.
Enfin, là où on est là où est le système
solaire et qu'on aurait plus assez
d'énergie, qu' faudrait commencer à
stocker des étoiles pour pouvoir lutter
contre le contre le l'expansion de
l'univers. parce que sinon dans 100
milliards d'années, on va avoir un
problème. Et alors en fait Laurent
Alexandre est encore plus fort, il va
plus loin parce que il s'inspire d'un
monsieur qui s'appelle Clément Vidal et
qui lui explique qu'en fait on peut
peut-être que l'univers a a émergé
à partir de d'une civilisation
extrêmement avancée qui en fait aurait
reconstruit son univers pour éviter la
la disparition de l'univers précédent.
Et donc Laurent Alexandre qui nous
prévoyait il y a quelques années la mort
de la mort et juste l'immortalité, un
truc assez simple pour le commun des
mortels. La maintenance, il nous propose
de lutter contre la mort de l'univers.
Alors c'est un job de quelques milliards
d'années, mais on pourrait s'y mettre
tout de suite. Il me semble que moi,
j'ai envie de traiter des problèmes plus
urgents et de contribuer à à des choses
un petit peu moins peut-être
prospectives quoi.
C'est quoi c'est quoi les problèmes plus
urgents que la science et la technologie
ne va pas nous permettre de nous
affranchir ? Alors, c'est une c'est une
vaste question parce que alors si les
problèmes purgents, ils sont assez
simples, on va dire c'est euh le
problème climatique. Bon, il faut
vraiment être obtu de nos jours pour euh
contester le fait qu'on a un problème
climatique. Alors après, on peut
discuter de que quels seront les
scénarios d'adaptation ou de ou de ou de
mitigation ou de ou de lutte contre ce
ce réchauffement climatique. la question
de la biodiversité qui est probablement
la plus aigue, enfin l'équilibre des des
systèmes, la pollution généralisée. Je
je lisais l'autre jour un article qui a
eu, je pense, pas mal de succès et qui
disait même au fin fond des Pyrénées, il
pleut du plastique. Donc en gros, c'est
il y a une station météorologique, enfin
des des scientifiques qui ont récupéré
des microplastiques, il en tombe 365 par
jour et par mètre carré au fin fond des
Pyrénées. Voilà. On dit "Mais qu'est-ce
que c'est que ces trucs avance avec
l'eau qui tombait du ciel n'était plus
potable depuis longtemps parce que elle
vient lécher ramasser un certain nombre
de pollutions gazeuses diverses et varié
mais maintenant elle vient aussi
ramasser des microparticules de
plastique. Alors d'où viennent ces
microparticules plastique ? C'est pas
les méchants coton tiges que la
Commission européenne a décidé
d'interdire. Bravo pour ce ces premiers
actes courageux si je puis dire. Euh ça
vient en fait notamment de l'usure des
pneus de de voiture, de la poussière des
villes, de l'érosion du du monde, de
l'usure de tous les objets qu'on utilise
et qui en fait crée des des
microplastiques. C'estàd que même s'il
en avait une voiture dite propre, même
si son énergie était propre, même si sa
fabrication était propre, même si la
gestion des déchets était propre, rien
que rouler, c'est un/ers des
microplastiques qui primaires qui
finissent dans l'océan chaque année.
Donc [grognement] la largeur de votre
pneu détermine le taux de pollution.
océanique que vous créez.
Alors, pardon, j'ai pas répondu à la
question du coup. Pardon ? Oui. Donc, ça
c'est un peu les problèm alors il y a un
trè problème qui est pour moi le
problème des ressources alors qui est
pas forcément euh de de très court
terme, c'est-à-dire qu'on en a encore
beaucoup sous le pied. Il y a des
questions de rendement décroissant, il y
a des questions de d'impact
environnemental qui augmentent au fur et
à mesure qu'on va chercher les choses
dans des endroits un petit peu plus
bizarres ou qu'on ira les chercher sous
les océans ou autres. Mais il y a un
moment ou un autre où on risque d'avoir
effectivement une des difficultés parce
que il y a cette interaction
systématique que j'avais expliqué dans
un premier passage chez vous entre
l'énergie et les ressources.
C'est-à-dire que l'énergie réclame des
ressources pour être capté, pour être
convertie, pour être utilisé et
réciproquement les ressources elles
réclament de l'énergie pour être
extraite, raffinée et utilisé également.
et que c'est ce ce jeu entre les deux
qui qui peut poser problème. Alors
aujourd'hui, j'ai l'impression qu'on est
on a un espèce de de renouveau d'un
certain nombre de débats historiques.
Euh il y a alors il y a un renouveau euh
notamment entre ce que moi j'ai appelé
dans les les cornuc enfin pas ce que
j'ai appelé mais j'ai essayé de revenir
sur ce débat là entre les cornucopiens
c'est ceux qui promettent l'abondance
par la technologie et puis les les
prophètes de l'apocalypse les Dooms
Deers disaient les les cornucopiens qui
qui se défendaient il y a quelques
dizaines d'années sur le sujet et c'est
en train de revenir complètement
au au goût du jour de la même manière
d'ailleurs que par exemple le débat
démographique est en train de
réapparaître. Je sais pas si vous avez
noté ça, mais on voit on voit venir un
petit peu dans les dans les magazines,
sur internet et cetera. Il y a des
livres qui commencent à être publiés sur
le sujet et voilà qui étaient des des
débats prégnants
dans les années 50 60 70 qui ont un peu
disparu dans les années 80 90 parce que
fin de l'histoire jute de l'URSS et
cetera du bloc soviétique et puis qui là
réapparaissent à l'orée des années 2020
et donc qui sont en train un peu de
s'exacerber.
Moi ce que j'ai essayé de de montrer
dans mon dans mon dernier bouquin, c'est
euh en fait ce débat-là, c'est assez
rigolo parce que il a même on pourrait
dire qu'il a quelques dizaines d'années,
mais il a bien plus que ça. Il a même
plusieurs siècles. On été là la promesse
de l'abondance par la technologie
appliquée, elle démarre avec Francis
Bacon, la nouvelle Atlantide en 1621
par là de mémoire vérifier la date. Donc
lui va théoriser pour la pour la pour la
première fois le fait que il y a la
science d'abord peut être systématisée
euh la science expérimentale qui permet
aussi de de découvrir des choses, de
tester des choses et qu'on va pouvoir
l'appliquer dans toute une série de
domaines euh dans la chimie, dans la
production de de de matériaux, dans la
médecine et cetera et et et d'ailleurs
ça donnera son ouvrage donnera la
contribuera à créer l'académie et euh
royal des sciences en Angleterre et puis
sur le même ensuite sur le même schéma
en France et ailleurs et [grognement] et
donc en fait dès le dès le début du 17e
siècle, il y a cette promesse un peu de
voilà la science va permettre le progrès
le progrès du genre humain. Le fait est
que d' enfin sur beaucoup de critères,
ça l'a effectivement permis. On va pas
nier ça évidemment. Alors en fait vite
ce qui est intéressant c'est que il faut
pas attendre la loi de mour des
microprocesseurs et puis je sais pas la
la puissance de de calcul et les
dernières découvertes en médecine pour
pour que les promesses un certain nombre
de promesses arrivent très vite. C'estd
dans dans le sillage de Francis Bacon,
on retrouve assez rapidement des écrits
dès le 17e siècle, 18e siècle où en fait
les les des penseurs des philosophes
vont se vont s'emballer un petit peu en
disant effectivement il y a il y a un
progrès phénoménal à ce moment-là, un
progrès des de la connaissance donc en
en chimie enfin dans plein de domaines
en et l'alchimie va vraiment devenir de
la de la chimie scientifique au 18e et
très vite en fait les promesses qui sont
les mêmes promesses qu'aujourd'hui vont
apparaître, c'estàd promesses sur le
toujours plus loin, toujours plus fort,
toujours plus vite, toujours plus de
consommation. Donc on va dire les
promesses cornucopiennes. Alors
c'est-à-dire que en gros la
terraformation de de Mars que que plus
ou moins nous propose
soit Elon Musk, soit Jeff Bessos euh est
déjà là au 18e siècle. Il y a voilà, il
y a déjà des gens qui disent on va on va
aller sur la Lune, on va voyager aussi
facilement sur la Lune que dans les
Amériques. Dit par exemple un philosophe
anglais comme Joseph Glanville qui dit
aussi au passage qu'on va réussir à
faire rajunir les cheveux gris. Donc
c'est pas de les les promesses de
repousser l'âge de la mort en fait
datent du 17e siècle. Elles sont déjà
là.
Fake news.
Fake news puisque la preuve en est.
Alors que le marché accessible est juste
gigantesque, je peux en témoigner. Si on
prend juste même les les les soins
capillaires, on est en dizaines de
milliards de dollars au niveau mondial
et les transhumanistes qui nous
proposent de repousser l'âge de la mort
arrivent pas à repousser l'âge de la
mort des cheveux. Je c'est quand même
assez hallucinant parce que un cheveux,
je veux bien que ça soit compliqué, mais
c'est quand même sans doute moins
compliqué qu'un corps humain complet, un
foie, des poumons, un intestin grê, que
sais-je ? Bon, donc c'est vrai qu'on
peut se poser des questions. Donc
cheveux gris dès le dès le 17e siècle.
Ensuite, au 18e siècle, il y a des
penseurs assez connus, hein, Condorsait
par exemple, qui des progrès de de de
l'esprit humain, euh qui va dans les
mêmes termes dire voilà, on va on va
réussir à repousser l'âge de la mort, à
augmenter l'espérance de vie. Il va pas
jusqu'à parler d'immortalité, mais il en
est très proche. Il y a aucune raison
qu'on augmente pas l'espérance de vie
humaine de manière indéfinie. Et en face
de de l'autre côté de la Manche, il y a
un monsieur qui s'appelle William Godwin
qui est aussi philosophe, un peu son son
pendant anglais et qui lui va franchir
le pas et va dire "Oui, on peut aller
jusqu'à une civilisation de d'être
immortel
et d'ailleurs ça sera une civilisation
d'adulte, il y aura plus d'enfants." Il
le dit pertinemment, ce qui est assez
intéressant parce que dans le discours
transhumaniste aujourd'hui, on entend
personne qui dit "Bah promis, il va y
avoir la on va repousser à je mais il y
aura plus d'enfant hein parce que faut
être d'accord là-dessus."
Euh donc et il dit bah ça comme ça la
vérité n'aura plus besoin de faire son
parcours à nouveau tous les 30 ans. Il
dit il y aura plus finalement on aura
appris une seule fois et on aura appris
à pas se battre. on aura appris la
démocratie, on aura appris un de choses
comme ça. Il y aura pas besoin chaque
génération de redémarrer et de refaire
les mêmes erreurs. Donc ça sera une
civilisation absolument idéal. Alors
pour
pour l'anecdote,
William Godwin, c'est le c'est le papa
de Marie Chelley Marie Chellet l'autrice
de de Frankenstein. Donc qui je sais pas
comment on étaient les repas chez chez
les chez les Godwin, mais voilà, elle va
elle va peut-être doucher un peu les
ardeurs transhumanistes et la question
de de de d'être capable de repousser
comme ça le la l'âge de la mort avec son
son papa qui était très enthousiaste. Et
pour la deuxième petite anecdote, c'est
que les écrits de Godwin et Conorsais
vont faire bondir un jeune monsieur qui
s'appelle Maltus évidemment et c'est en
fait les écrits expliquant que on allait
être de plus en plus nombreux et vivre
de plus en plus longtemps et que tout ça
n'allait poser aucun problème qui va qui
va le le pousser à écrire un petit peu
rapidement d'abord une première version
de de son essai sur la population
qu'ensuite succès aidant il va un petit
peu raffiner en voyageant en Europe et
en ayant en allant voir un petit peu
tous les tous les problèmes que que crée
la surpopulation ou pas. Voilà. Donc
c'est c'est on est déjà dans des dans
dans des promesses de ce type là. Et
puis alors le 19e siècle euh va apporter
quelque chose d'un petit peu nouveau.
Mais mais là aussi alors les les progrès
évidemment technologiques sont
fulgurant. La révolution industrielle
est là, les progrès scientifiques, on va
voir l'émergence de la chimie d'abord,
la chimie industrielle qui va permettre
de d'amender les sols. On commence à
comprendre qu'il faut rajouter du
nitrate, de la potasse et du phosphate
avec les bigs. Euh donc on va promettre
grâce à la chimie, on va on va résoudre
la fin dans le monde. Donc la même
manière qu'aujourd'hui, on pourrait dire
les les promoteurs des OGM nous disent
aussi qu'on va résoudre la fin dans le
monde.
On a des gens qui vont parler d'aller
conquérir d'autres systèmes solaires
évidemment puisqueon commence à savoir
que on n plus tout à fait dans le
système galiléen ni copernicien. Donc on
on sait qu'il y a d'autres d'autres
systèmes solaires, donc on va pouvoir
aller les conquérir et vont apparaître
quand même les premières dystopies,
c'està-dire par rapport à ces utopies
sont plutôt des utopies technologiques,
hein.
Alors ça va apparaître d'ailleurs dans
les dans des dans des articles, dans des
essais, mais ça va paraître aussi
évidemment dans la littérature, hein.
C'estàd que on va avoir à la fois des
des gens comme Jul Verne plutôt le on va
dire cornucopien un peu sympathique et
voilà, on va aller voyager dans la lune
et cetera et puis on va avoir WS qui lui
évidemment va à la fois explorer le côté
le côté sombre et le côté positif de de
de l'évolution technologique.
Bon voilà et tout ça pour dire on arrive
ensuite au on va arriver dans les années
30 40 50 et là le débat va vraiment
prendre forme entre des des lanceurs
d'alerte on pourrait dire ça comme ça ça
s'appelle pas comme ça encore à l'époque
mais c'estàd plutôt un mouvement de
conservationniste américain donc dans
les années 30
enfin fin des années 30 40 on a le aux
États-Unis le dust ball donc les les
plusieurs étates le claoma et ceter les
grandes plaines sont vont s'éroder très
rapidement Enfin, c'est la culture
première culture du maïs et cetera qui
va un peu épuiser les sols. Donc il y a
il y a un vrai mouvement
conservationniste qui se met en place
notamment autour effectivement de la
conservation des sols, donc des
scientifiques et cetera. Et on a
notamment deux personnes, s'appelle
William Vog. Euh il est ornitologue à
l'origine,
il écrit un un bouquin qui s'appelle
enfin qui a été traduit en français par
La fin dans le monde, la fin du monde
pardon. Alors la fin F A I évidemment,
jeu de mots un petit peu un petit peu
bête.
Et puis une deuxième personne qui
s'appelle Fairfield Osborne. Lui c'est
il est président de la New York
Zological Society. C'est le fils de d'un
célèbre paleéontologue américain par
ailleurs qui a découvert plusieurs
dinosaures enf dans les la fin du 19e
siècle. et
et lui va écrire Our Plundered Planet,
la planète au pillage. Donc qui va à la
fois parler de du pillage des ressources
au sens ressources renouvelable, donc
les forêts, les sols justement,
l'épuisement des sols par l'agriculture
et puis aussi un peu la question des des
ressources minérales, même si c'est
abordé de manière assez assez succinte
dans dans l'ouvrage. Ces deux bouquins,
ils datent tous les deux de 1948, juste
à la sortie de la Seconde Guerre
mondiale et ils vont poser le le premier
débat en fait. euh sur la technologie et
sur le progrès, c'est-à-dire que ces ces
gens-là vont dire très rapidement euh on
est on est déjà trop nombreux. Voilà,
c'est enfin c'est ce qu'ils disent. On
va devenir surtout de plus en plus
nombreux, on consomme de plus en plus et
l'ensemble de ces deux courbes va faire
exploser les compteurs et on va aller
vers on pourrait dire, il l'appelle pas
tout à fait comme ça, mais vers un
effondrement. Voilà. Et donc, ils vont
écrire pendant toutes les années 50, ils
vont écrire pendant les années 60. Dans
les années 60, ils sont rejoints par un
monsieur qui s'appelle Paul Ernich.
Polerlich 1968 The Population Bombin,
la bombe P en français et donc qui alors
lui il est il est biologiste aussi he
c'est c'est un spécialiste des papillons
à l'origine Hernich et donc voilà ils
vont ils vont continuer comme ça René
Dumont premier premier candidat si on
passe côté français à la présidentielle
de 60 je sais plus combien 12 peut-être
non il y a pas de présidentiel 72 peu
importe 74
va écrire en 66 un livre qui s'appelle
nous allons à la famine et qui prévoit
la famine mondiale avant les enfin
autour des années 80 quoi. Donc on est
quand même dans des dans des écrits
assez sérieux. Enfin, je aujourd'hui il
y a des bouquins qui sortent et qui
disent les mêmes choses.
Mais voilà, c'est c'est ce débat là, il
est déjà ici. Et alors ce qui est
intéressant, c'est que très vite dès la
fin des années 40 aussi, au tout début
des années 50, on va avoir en face des
gens. Alors là, c'est pas des gens qui
sont tellement issus du monde euh
scientifique ou des sciences dures.
C'est plutôt des gens issus des sciences
sociales, des économistes, des
futurologues. Le métier de futurologue
est inventé. C'est notamment l'armée de
l'air des États-Unis qui va en fait
subventionner un certain nombre de de
single tank de de de voilà de
d'officines, d'études sur le futur.
Alors, c'est notamment lié aux questions
un peu de d'évolution géopolitique, de
question autour du nucléaire, de la
guerre nucléaire et cetera. Donc voilà,
c'est ces gens vont s'autoprogrammer les
futurologues et et très vite ils vont
dire n'importe quoi. C'est c'est ce que
racontent ces dou enfin c'est ces ces
prophètes de malheur
ils sont tous plantés.
Alors par oui, exact. Ils se plantent.
Ils se plantent et l'énorme erreur
qu'ils font c'est euh qu'il néglige le
progrès technologique. Qu'est-ce que
c'est que cette histoire ? Il nous
projette des courbes, des trucs. Mais il
y a du progrès technologique. Il y en a
eu pendant tout le 19e siècle. Il est
fulgurant. Il a été fulgurant notamment
entre les deux guerres. enfin grâce aux
deux guerres mondiales. Et donc c'est
c'est tout à fait le contraire. Au lieu
d'aller vers un monde qui est plus
contraint, qui est plus difficile, euh
qui est plus qui qui va mener à des
pénuries, on va au contraire faire un
monde de l'abondance grâce aux
technologies. Alors, il y a des gens euh
la plupart ont été oubliés, mais par
exemple
Buckminster Fuller, donc euh l'inventeur
du dô Géodésique qui un peu un peu un
architecte un peu touche à tout euh qui
lui va dès les années 30, mais il va il
va surtout écrire dans les années 50, il
invente le concept d'éphéméralisation,
donc on dirait aujourd'hui
dématérialisation. et il dit "Bah vous
voyez, il y avait des fils de télégraphe
en cuivre, on a inventé la radio. Bah
voilà, maintenant on transmet les
informations par rond de radio, il y a
plus besoin de télégraphe. Donc on va
économiser des ressources et on va faire
plus avec moins de ressources. On va
réussir à avoir plus de services, plus
de confort. Et même les bâtiments,
regardez, moi au lieu de faire des trucs
en poteau poutre, béton, hyper lourd et
cetera, on va faire des domôes
géodésiques. Je les ai inventé, ça tombe
bien. Et c'est beaucoup plus léger et
c'est des structures qui consomment
moins de ressources. Et puis vous avez
donc ces futurologues. Alors on a oublié
un peu leur nom. Il y a des gens comme
Alvin Toffler qui a écrit la trisème
vague, des gens comme Herman Kan, Herman
Kan, lui trava justement travaillait
pour l'armée de l'air américaine qui va
écrire l'an 2000. Il écrit ça en 1967
1968. C'est un bestseller mondial. Et
alors quand vous reprenez le bouquin 50
ans après, c'est juste hallucinant. Donc
c'est les bases lunaires, les voitures
volantes, les les les riches en gros
parce que ils ont des ont des fusées
hypersonique et les pauvres se baladent
dans des bétaillères supersoniques parce
que bah voilà, ils ont pas le moyen de
se payer une fusée personnelle. On
repousse l'âge de la mort. Euh on
imagine qu'on va faire une conquête
effectivement galactique déjà euh qui
commencera d'abord évidemment par
l'installation de base lunaire et
jusqu'au tout début des années 80, un
monsieur assez truculant B Julan Simon
euh économiste qui était euh qui qui
écrit en 1980 un bouquin qui s'appelle
The Ultimate Ressource qui parle de
alors Ultimate Ressource c'est la
ressource ultime que les géologues
parlent de ressources ultim donc c'est
un clin d'œil à à la question de est-ce
qu'il y aura pénuriie ou pas de
ressources géologiques Et et ce gars
voilà va dire "Non, la ressource ultime
c'est l'homme, c'est l'être humain."
Parce que plus on sera nombreux, plus on
aura des chercheurs, des techniciens,
des ingénieurs, plus on va repousser la
pénurie parce qu'au contraire justement
on va faire du progrès technologique. et
lui en ou 82, il dit qu'on va démarrer
la l'exploitation lunaire minière en
1990 et que avant l'an 2000, on aura 50
millions de tonnes de panneaux solaires
autour de la Terre pour
fournir l'ensemble de l'électricité qui
sera nécessaire. Donc c'est quand même
des gens qui faisaient déjà des
projections très rapides. On voit
d'ailleurs qu'aujourd'hui on est en 2019
et on a des gens qui se projettent assez
rapidement sur 2025 2030 maximum 2035
parce que justement les exponentiels qui
montent jusqu'au ciel très rapidement
une fois qu'on est dans le dans le creux
de la courbe donne envie un peu à tout
le monde de s'emballer. Mais voilà,
c'est pas la première fois qu'on nous
fait le coup qu'on nous dit qu'on va
aller vers l'abondance, qu'on a toutes
les solutions que la science a trouvé.
Mais aussi c'est pas le la première fois
qu'on nous fait le coup, c'est la fin du
monde.
Exactement. C'est ça qui est un petit
peu difficile là, c'est que
effectivement de l'autre côté, on a eu
des gens qui ont hurlé au loup sur le
fait que ça allait s'effondrer et le
fait est qu'il y a eu effectivement
progrès enfin progrès oui développement
technologique qui a permis de repousser
un certain nombre de pénuries. Euh et
alors le problème c'est qu'il y a quand
même un paramètre qui a bougé entre les
deux, c'est la c'est la destruction euh
voilà d'un certain nombre de de de
de biotopes, la le la l'écroulement de
de de la biodiversité alors que ça soit
en en qualité ou en quantité parce qu'il
y a plein d'espèces qui ont pas disparu
physiquement mais dont on sait que voilà
90 % 95 % des effectifs ont on ont
disparu et puis cette on pourrait dire
cette pollution généralisé qui quand on
prend la question du voilà du plastique
par exemple mais évidemment des
pesticides d'un certain nombre de de de
produits non biodégradables. Bon voilà
c'est c'est ce que je dis je disais un
petit peu en plaisant les ingénieurs ne
font pas d'omelettes sans casser des
œufs. Voilà on a fait des omelettes, on
a trouvé vous inquiétez pas on a tous
toujours de quoi se chauffer. On a même
jamais autant consommé de d'énergie. On
a plein d'appareils à notre disposition.
Le confort entre guillemets a a
fortement augmenté.
d'une certaine manière l'espérance de
vie, même si sur l'espérance de vie
c'est plus les chiffres sont pervers, on
peut y revenir quelques secondes, mais
euh voilà. Mais par contre, il a fallu
pour ça aller chercher et à creuser,
mettre des barrages, enfin faire un
certain nombre de choses pour pour
permettre ça. Donc effectivement, on
pourrait dire un partout la balle au
centre. Euh euh
d'une certaine manière, oui, sauf que
sauf que on est rattrapé aujourd'hui par
la question sans doute plus par la
question des limites planétaires que par
la question des ressources. D'ailleurs,
il y a ce ce
discours un petit peu compliqué autour
du pic de pétrole. Pic de pétrole.
Vient, on y vient. Qu'est-ce que vous
Qu'est-ce que vous connaissez au pic du
pétrole ?
J'en connais ce qu'and disent les
spécialistes, hein. Je suis pas je suis
pas géologue pétrolier. Donc il y a
effectivement ce pic de pétrole
conventionnel dont tout le monde
reconnaît que même le l'agence
internationale d'énergie qu'il a été
passé en 2008 je crois ou peut-être même
2006 voilà ça c'est voilà le check pour
la communauté il faut leur laisser deux
trois trucs quand même. [grognement]
Bon et malheureusement aujourd'hui on
doit être à peu près à 100 millions de
baril jours de de production [soupir]
et en fait le ça ne diminue pas bien au
contraire et la différence a été amenée
par les pétroes les pétroes de Rochem
les pétroes non conventionnels. Bon, par
ailleurs, il y a aussi les les gaz
d'idochiste, donc non conventionnel
également qui bon font partie du mix
énergétique et qui ont permis eux aussi
de d'accéder à une énergie relativement
à bon marché.
Et donc voilà, on on sait aujourd'hui,
enfin on commence à dire aujourd'hui oui
alors enfin il y a deux positions pour
dire il y a une première position qui
est une position on pourrait dire un peu
écolo qui est de dire bah il y en a
tellement dans le sous-sol et le fait
est qu'il y en a beaucoup et alors si je
rajoute les hydrates de méthane et je
sais pas quoi les trucs du permafrost
c'est juste colossal donc il faut en
laisser 80 % dans le sous-sol parce que
sinon ça va être ça ça va être la bésina
climatique. Le fait est qu'on est quand
même un peu parti pour ça. Pour
l'instant, j'ai pas je ne vois aucun
signal, on pourra y revenir un peu plus
tard, mais qui permettent de dire que la
tendance pas le réchauffement
climatique. On a entendu une géographe
il y a pas très longtemps sur un plateau
télé dire "Mais vous savez dans les pays
du nord, ils sont très contents avec le
réchauffement climatique, ça leur ouvre
des routes commerciales."
Alors ça c'est oui, ça ouvre la la le
passage du nord-ouest.
Euh donc ça raccourcit de quelques
semaines euh
la version Chine Europe ou Chine
États-Unis. Bon alors c'est l'été
d'abord pour l'instant parce que on
n'est pas encore un niveau de
réchauffement climatique qui fait qu'il
y aurait plus de glace l'hiver. Enfin
bon, ça ça après tout ça ça pour ça
pourrait bien venir.
Il y a peut-être effectivement enfin
c'est même probable des endroits où le
réchauffement climatique planétaire
peut être intéressant. J'en sais rien.
En Russie, ils sont plutôt branchés hein
par le par le réchauffement climatique.
Enfin, ça va mettre des ça peut mettre
des terres en culture et cetera. Donc
ils sont pas du tout stressés à ma
connaissance de de ça.
Ils sont un peu stressés par les
épidémies de malaria, le paludisme,
toutes les tous les insectes qui tous
les insectes et les virus qui étaient
relativement circonscrits.
Alors oui, est-ce qu'il y a des quelques
trucs du paléolitique qui traînent
peut-être et qui vont se réveiller ? Bon
oui, effectivement. Alors ça c'est
l'autre
on peut faire la liste des 10 pl
d'Égypte. Effectivement, la question
c'est alors finir sur les ressources
peut-être. C'estàd que moi je pense pas
que les ressources
donc pardon, il y avait la vision écolo
qui de dire faut en laisser 80 % dans le
sol mais on comprend pas bien comment on
va réussir à s'autocontreindre en disant
oui oui faut surtout pas les exploiter
puisque évidemment il faudrait que tout
le monde soit d'accord pour les laisser
dedans. Le premier qui fait un trou bah
l'autre va dire mais attends pourquoi
toi tu vas le chercher moi pas donc on
voit que ça va être très compliqué. Il y
a une version plus euh économiste
peut-être. la Norvage qui a renoncé à à
euh l'exploitation d'un de ses
principaux champs pour les questions
écologique ?
Oui. Alors, je sais pas si c'est pour
des est-ce que c'est pour des raisons
écologiques ou c'est pour se dire je
garde quelques C'est vrai que la Norvège
est un peu spéciale d'un point de vue
géographique parce que déjà il y a une
partie hydroélectrique est énorme. Donc
effectivement il ils ont eu la capacité
à se s'affranchir quand même d'un
certain nombre de ils font plus
facilement de l'électromobilité. Voilà,
ils vont ils vont ils vont ils peuvent
décarboner parce qu'ils ont
effectivement un espèce de de de
scandale géographique si je puis dire
sur les énergies renouvelable exception
qui confirme la
voilà. Bon donc peut-être il peut faire
ça. Alors après, il se trouve que le
fond le fond de retraite norvégien voilà
a fait tout son beurre sur les sur la
production d'hydrocarbure dans les
années 70 80 90 et et voilà aujourd'hui
ils peuvent investir et disent on sort
on sort du du charbon et cetera. Très
bien. S'ouvre
voilà. Mais bon voilà, personne n n'est
tout à fait clean, soit dans le présent,
soit dans le passé, ça dépend des cas.
Donc on peut parler de dette climatique
et d'autres sujets comme ça. Voilà. Non,
l'autre l'autre vision, c'est qui est
une vision moins plus économiste ou plus
géologico-énergétique,
on pourrait dire, c'est le fait de dire
non, en fait, il y a des bulles. Euh
c'est gaz de chiste, c'est pétrole de
rochmer, c'est des bulles, ce sont des
bulles. Euh il y a une espèce de voilà
de il y a trop d'argent, ça c'est pour
le coup, c'est vrai, on sait c'est voilà
le quantitat divising déverse des
quantités phénoménales de d'argent
disponibles. Quand vous avez de
l'argent, c'est-à-dire en gros des
électrons quelque part sur un disque
dur, vous dites "Ou là là ! Ouh là là !
Qu'est-ce que je vais faire de cet
argent ? Je Si vous prêtez à la Suisse
ou à l'Allemagne, c'est à taux d'intérêt
négatif, pas terrible. Et donc, il faut
trouver des endroits où investir. Alors,
ça peut être les start-ups d'Elon Musk
ou bien des trucs des des
startup de Laurent Alexandre.
Ouais. Éventuellement ou euh ou
effectivement des exploitations un petit
peu plus farfelu peut-être. Et donc il y
a il y a des mais c'est très difficile
de réussir à se faire une opinion
complètement tranchée. Mais voilà, il y
a il y a des gens qui disent que il y a
un peu un phénomène de bulle dans cette
dans cette exploitation dans cette
courbe de croissance incroyable de
production de pétrole non conventionnel
aux États-Unis he qui est aujourd'hui
c'est redevenu un un producteur majeur
je crois même peut-être le premier
producteur de pétrole au monde alors
qu'ils étaient ultra dépendants il y a
il y a 10 15 ans. C'est c'est juste
hallucinant effectivement c'est c'est
incontestable mais voilà mais il y a des
gens qui disent ça va pas durer parce
que en fait non non ça va se ça ça va se
retourner parce qu'en fait c'est une
bulle financière c'est une production
qui consomme beaucoup de ressources
beaucoup de d'énergie pour pour produire
et qu'en fait en réalité ça va ça va
s'écrouler bon voilà il y a ces deux
visions là et puis alors on pourrait
dire une troisème vision qui serait de
dire bah non plus ou moins business as
usual pour l'instant il y en a tellement
on a tellement sous le pied quand bien
même on aurait quelques difficultés de
pétrole ici ou
Bah après tout, pourquoi pas faire du
col to liquid, liquifier le charbon,
liquifier le gaz, on a plus de gaz que
de pétrole et que finalement voilà, s'il
y a pas de limite un peu réglementaire,
si je peux dire, ou économique sur la
partie rejet, enfin émission de CO2, bah
en fait voilà, on arrivera toujours à
enfin pas toujours pas jusqu'à la
civilisation galactique de niveau 2,
mais en tout cas pour quelques années,
décennies, j'en sais rien,
on arrivera bien à à on arrivera bien à
à combler le un déficit éventuel. Et
donc il y a il y a voilà en permanence
cette espèce de jeu à se faire peur ou
pas sur le mode à la lame, il va falloir
découvrir l'équivalent d'une Arabie
Saoudite dans les 10 ans ou dans les 5
ans ou qui en fait souvent un jeu
d'ailleurs porté plus par les acteurs
pétroliers eux-mêmes hein sur le mode
ouvrez-nous un peu vos marchés là
l'Iran, le Venezuela le truc parce que
faut mettre des choses en production.
C'est pas vraiment forcément porté un
discours qui est porté par les écolos et
du coup moi j'ai du mal un peu même si
je sais que j'ai j'ai un peu démarrer
sur ça. On pourrait dire j'ai du mal à
me dire que le
ce problème énergético géologique qui
existe qui existera c'est que la cette
civilisation n'est pas durable c'est pas
possible on peut le dire alors à moins
de de se dire qu'on va dans les dans les
les autres sur les autres planètes les
astéroïdes et tout on pourrait y revenir
si on veut voir un peu le niveau de
crédibilité de ça.
Mais j'ai du mal à croire que ça soit
c'est ça qui fasse basculer. Voilà.
Pourquoi c'est pas crédible d'aller
chercher des astéroïdes, de mettre des
astéroïdes en orbite autour de la terre,
de les exploiter ? Pourquoi ?
Pourquoi ça vous paraît surréaliste ?
Alors, il y avait un
je crois que c'est dans George Jescour,
Nicolas Georgescourgen, un des papes de
la décroissance qui est dans un ses
bouquins ou dans un cart article pour
des gourous. Oui, gourou, on pourrait
dire ou dessin je sais pas quand on vous
dit voilà, il y a les nouveaux gourous
qui émergent, les collapsologues,
les catastrophistes hologues, les les
cassandres, ceux qui voient tout en
noir. Quand on vous dit que vous êtes
une cassandre, ça vous fait quoi ? Moi,
je suis le moins je suis le moins
catastrophiste de de de mes amis
collapsologues de de loin, je pense.
C'est-à-dire que moi, je crois plus à
une à nouveau, je je d'abord je pense
qu'il faut pas hurler au loup trop vite
et trop fort. C'est-à-dire que prétendre
par exemple que l'effondrement est
inéluctable avant 2030 me paraît
écologique.
Alors bah tout dépend ce qu'on appelle
voilà l'effondrement écologique, il est
derrière nous. Enfin, moi le euh le
passé m'inquiète plus que que l'avenir,
hein. Faire faire
était pour demain, c'est ça ?
Alors, ben oui, alors j'ai enfin j'ai
d'ailleurs la dédicace, c'est à tous
ceux que le passé inquiète qui est un
petit qui est un petit pied de nez en
fait à la dédicace de Ferfield d'Osborn
qui avait écrit son bouquin. Il l'avait
dédié à tous ceux que l'avenir inquiète.
Voilà, moi le passé m'inquiète autant
que l'avenir parce que je vois ce qu'on
a été capable de faire et donc quelque
part je je me projette dans l'avenir par
rapport à à toutes les limites morales,
physiques et cetera qu'on a pu enfoncer
au cours de ces monstrueux 19e et 20e
siècle. Donc voilà, je pense que il peut
se passer pas mal de choses. Non, moi je
crois pas que enfin je mets pas moi je
mets pas les ressources. Les ressources
est un vrai problème, je dirais moral et
philosophique parce que si la société
n'est pas durable, bon la manière dont
on a fait fonctionner aujourd'hui, moi
j'ai rien contre le dentiste du 21e
siècle. J'adore les radiodumériques et
voilà. Après bon, on peut discuter des
limites éthiques dans la médecine, mais
bon, il y a quand même des trucs qui
sont vraiment sympas. Le dentiste des
années 80, c'était quand même moins
bien. Il y a pas de problème. On peut
tous le reconnaître, je crois. Bon
voilà, la question c'est quand est-ce
qu'il y a encore le dentiste ? en l'an
2100 ou en l'an 2200 ou en l'an 2500 ou
est-ce que c'est les visiteurs quoi.
Est-ce qu'il nous reste des dents ?
Voilà. Est-ce que voilà c'est est-ce que
c'est le retour au Moyen-âge pour de
vrai ou est-ce qu'on a réussi à
maintenir à quelque part à séparer le
grain de livret ? Et moi, c'est ça qui
m'intéresse c'est et évidemment c'est
toujours extrêmement difficile dans la
question technologique de séparer les
bons usages des mes usages et il y a
forcément des paramètres qui sont des
des paramètres moraux, des paramètres
éthiques, philosophiques qui fait que on
peut pas exactement tracer une
frontière. C'est c'est jamais très
simple. Mais moi je pense que le je
reviens sur mes 10 d'Égypte, c'estàd que
il y a plein d'autres facteurs qui me
paraissent disons
aussi embêtant que alors pour les coup
pour le coup j'en suis pas un
spécialiste mais on pourrait dire des
questions d'antibiorésistance
des questions de la version gripavière
plus parce que bah voilà à force de
mélanger
des élevages concentrationnaires de
cochon
de de poule et d'humain. Bah voilà, tout
ça ça finit par muter un peu de temps en
temps et puis voilà, je sais pas ce que
est-ce que ça peut donner quelque chose
de compliqué ou pas. La question
financière évidemment la bulle la bulle
financière la prochaine bulle, elle
éclate, elle éclate pas, on sauve les
banques, on les sauve pas, c'est
systémique, c'est pas systémique.
C'est et dans tous les esprits, je
pense, notamment des gens qui y
travaillent. Euh qu'est-ce qu'on peut
trouver ? les questions de
les questions de déliquence
de la société. Enfin, il y a je crois
qu' des bouquins en ce moment qui marche
bien et sur l'archipel français par
exemple et le fait que voilà, on est
peut-être en train de faire de plus en
plus au lieu de faire de faire de
réussir à faire société, on est en train
d'atomiser peut-être les notions les les
différentes euh les différentes valeurs,
les différentes manières de de de voir
les choses et que voilà, est-ce que
peut-être que ça sera plus compliqué
dans le monde de de demain ? et que au
lieu d'aller finalement vers le village
global planétaire fantastique avec des
consommatecteurs informés
l'économie circulaire l'économie et
cetera peut-être en fait non finalement
on va vers des des des mondes plus
nucléarisés
avec des des conflits potentiels plus
importants, des gens qui se comprennent
moins bien. Finalement, on aura
peut-être des outils de on aura
peut-être on aura même certain qu'on
aura des outils très performants de
traduction, mais on se comprendra quand
même moins bien, même si on parle si on
est capable de parler la même langue
parce qu'on aura pas on aura pas les
mêmes le même système de valeur. Alors,
c'est pas forcément nouveau euh mais
voilà, on peut on peut se dire que ça ça
peut prendre des ampleurs à mon avis
importantes. La question politique. Bon
voilà, on sait bien que voilà à chaque
élection on sert un peu les fesses de c
de là sur quelle sauce on va être mangé
ou tel ou tel pays. On le Brésil machin
États-Unis. Bon, moi je voilà, je moi je
suis pas spécialiste de tout ça, mais je
je constate comme un citoyen que voilà,
il y a plein il y a plein d'autres
choses et que le premier problème n'est
peut-être pas le fait d'avoir je sais
pas quoi, une pénurie d'indium pour les
écrans tactiles parce que [grognement]
voilà ou les écrans plats, bon, on
survit sans écrans tactiles dans les
boulangeries peut-être. Bon, à un
moment, il faudra peut-être flécher de
manière un peu plus intelligente tel ou
tel produit, telle ou telle pénurie. Il
y a aussi cette formidable formidable
capacité d'innovation et d'adaptation.
Le fait est enfin pour le meilleur et
pour le pire le produit Alexandre. Non
non mais sur le fait que effectivement
face à des pénuries potentielles de tel
ou tel produit
en tout cas conjoncturel ou ponctuel ou
temporaire bah il y a quand même des
réactions. Il y a un peu d'innovation.
Enfin je sais pas tous les produits, les
métaux rares, les machins qu'on utilise
dans nos smartphones et cetera. Bon, il
y a il y a derrière il y a toujours des
histoires de performance ou de prix.
Donc [soupir] dans un smartphone,
j'avais fait le calcul pour
lors d'une discussion avec Guillaume
Pit, enfin après une discussion avec
Guillaume Pitron
et j'avais calculé qu'il y avait moins
de 2 € de métau rares, de terre rares,
de tout ce qu'on veut dans un
smartphone. Moins de 2 €. La moitié
c'est de l'or dans le microprocesseur 30
mg à 30000 € ça fait de l'ordre de 1 €
ou un peu moins. Et puis le reste
quelques poudes de perle pimpin,
palladium, platine, que sais-je ? en
quantité tellement petite que ça
représente peanuts à la fin 2 € dans un
smartphone. Donc se dire que le monde va
s'écrouler parce que parce que je sais
pas, on va se retrouver avec des
produits qui peut-être à un moment vont
décupler
en en prix. Bah si ça décuple, ça
coûtera 20 € dans le smartphone. À ma
connaissance, un smartphone, il y a
plein d'autres. Il y a une on achète pas
à 2 € onachète bien plus cher. On achète
parce qu'il y a de la marge, parce qu'il
y a du développement, parce qu'il y a de
la fabrication, parce qu'il y a plein de
choses comme ça.
Des taxes.
Des taxes, oui, de la TVA évidemment et
puis de la de l'amortissement des
usines, des voilà. Donc du coup, bon
évidemment qu'à un moment il la à
nouveau la contrainte, elle va arriver,
elle arrivera, je sais pas sous quelle
forme et comment. À mon avis, moi je
préfère la désescalade, on pourrait
dire, ou une sorte de débacle plutôt que
le dire effondrement. Je pense pas que
les Je pense pas qu'il y a effondrement,
je pense pas qu'il y ait Ou alors il
sera protéiforme. Il dépendra de
plus une lentagonie.
Ouais, moi je ouais je je verrai ça
comme ça effectivement une lente
descente énergétique. Alors qui et à
nouveau qui pourra tout à fait être deal
d'un point de vue d'un point de vue
social. C'estàd qu' il y a des gens qui
continueront à se payer des choses très
chères et qui pourront continuer à se
déplacer très bien et puis d'autres
peut-être qui seront plus contraints.
Est-ce que c'est pas déjà un peu le cas
aujourd'hui ?
au gilets jaunes.
Oui, alors les gilets jaunes.
Oui, les gilets jaunes. Alors, les
gilets jaunes, je j'aurais plus loin
parce que je pense que le
je pense pas que le bon, il y a il y a
il y a cette espèce de de effectivement
de de d'éléments déclencheur de la taxe
carbone qui effectivement peut-être met
le feu au poudre, mais je pense que
c'est beaucoup plus profond le mouvement
des gilets jaunes. Il y a il y a
vraiment une question sur la sur la
question démocratique, sur la question
de de la cette déconnexion entre les
entre les élites et puis le le le petit
peuple, si je puis dire voilà qui qui
est rapidement venu au devant de la
scène, je pense en tout cas voilà et
c'est comme ça peut-être que les médias
ont traité ont traité le sujet.
[grognement]
Voilà. Donc du coup voilà, moi je vois
je vois voilà il y a toute une série
d'éléments qui peuvent être très
embêtants qui vont rendre le monde très
très compliqué mais il est déjà de toute
manière très compliqué. [grognement]
Voilà les ressources et énergie s'en est
un parmi d'autres. Est-ce que c'est
voilà je suis ingénieur et peut-être
moins moins déterministe que d'autres
collègues ingénieurs et je suis pas
certain que ça soit effectivement un
élément déclencheur.
On en a tellement sous le pied à nouveau
quand je regarde la la consommation de
de la consommation par exemple de
carburant. Imaginons qu'on ait
effectivement un pic de pétrole qui
passe et que ça devient vraiment tendu
et que il faille faire - 5 % par an ou
je sais pas moins 3 % par an pendant 10
20 30 ans. Bon, du coup, ça va très très
vite quelque part, mais aujourd'hui, il
y a peut-être allez 30 % de la
consommation de pétrole qui est une
consommation purement de de loisir,
enfin de pétrole dans les voitures parce
que c'est voilà, c'est les weekends,
c'est les vacances, c'est bon, c'est pas
c'est pas juste la partie contrainte des
déplacements domicile travail, c'est pas
juste la partie contrainte des camions
qui doivent alimenter les supermarchés
parisiens, c'est c'est aussi plein
d'autres choses. face à éventuellement
une pénurie qui ferait augmenter les
prix, bah il y aura une sorte
d'ajustement de comportement. En 2009,
après la crise, enfin pendant la crise,
les gens sont effectivement partis moins
loin en vacances, en moyenne euh parce
que il y avait moins de pouvoir d'achat
pour ceux qui pouvaient se le permettre.
Qu'est-ce qui vous pose de comme
problème avec le point de vue de Laurent
Alexandre ? Est-ce qu'il y a d'autres
facettes de ces arguments qui vous
irissent le poil ?
Ouais, il y en a plein. Alors euh trois
alors
bon alors d'abord je trouve que bon il a
il a quand même des il est quand même
connu pour ses jugements à
l'emporte-pièce mais je pense que ça
c'est la c'est sa marque de fabrique.
Donc moi je moi je suis plutôt toujours
un peu dans le doute que dans la
certitude. Donc lui c'est un peu
l'inverse j'ai l'impression. Euh façon
tout dernier papier, il me semble qu'il
date d'aujourd'hui ou d'hier, euh c'est
le ministre de l'agriculture français va
euh propose un système qui va amener des
centaines de millions de personnes à la
famine, hein. C'est lui le c'est lui le
prophète de l'apocalypse, c'est plus
moi. Euh alors sur le mode bah oui, si
vous voulez faire du bio, de la
policulture élevage, revenir un peu à à
ce que faisaient nos grands-parents,
effectivement, il y a eu ces mots un
petit peu bizarres de du ministre de de
l'agriculture.
Et ben vous allez mettre du coup comme
les rendements sont moins importants, on
perd 30 % 40 % peut-être de de rendement
en céréal, bah forcément vous allez
mettre des centaines de millions de
personnes, vous allez faire mourir des
centaines de millions de personnes. Mais
non, ça marche pas. C'est pas vrai.
Aujourd'hui, 70 % des céréales mondiales
sont utilisés pour nourrir des animaux.
Donc si vous mangez juste deux fois
moins de viande, j'admets que dans les
pays où il y a des classes moyennes
émergentes en développement, la
consommation de viande a plutôt tendance
à augmenter. Donc il faut je sais pas
tout ce que tout ce que ça pourrait
donner au niveau du mix mondial, mais on
va juste prendre un pays comme comme la
France. Si on mangeait tous deux fois
moins de viande, je parle pas de devenir
végétarien et cmer vert. Il y a des gens
qui peut-être veulent ou sont
végétariens et tant mieux. D'autres
d'autres d'autres sont plutôt
flexivores, je sais pas quoi, mais juste
divisé par deux la quantité de viande.
C'est en gros ça veut dire que le
français et moyen mangerait de la viande
que le midi ou que le soir et pas deux
fois par jour parce que c'est quand même
à peu près ça aujourd'hui hein, ce
concert dans les cantines ou et cetera.
Bah vous libérez des tombeaux de
céréales
donc vous pouvez absolument vous
permettre de baisser les rendements.
C'est c'est possible et ça emmène
personne à la famille. Donc il y a quand
même un peu de voilà, il y a du il y a
de la fake news euh qui qui traîne dans
ces jugements un petit peu euh un petit
peu rapides.
2è point
2è point euh
j'ai pas encore réussi à comprendre euh
ce qu'était vraiment sa position sur
l'intelligence artificielle et puis le
point de sa régularité de Kurtvil. C'est
ce cette espèce de logique. Alors, il
était dans les années 2030 je crois,
puis maintenant il a repoussé à 2045 ou
alors ce qui est bien avec les
exponentiels, c'est que ça peut être
2042, 2045 en quelques années. De toute
façon, on monte très vite au ciel. Donc
cette émergence d'une super intelligence
he ce qu'on appelle l'IA fort qui ferait
bah voilà de toute manière on aurait on
aurait des machines qui euh
[soupir][souffle coupé]
qui euh voilà seraient des allez on va
dire ça comme ça des milliards de fois
plus intelligentes que l'ensemble de nos
cerveaux réunis. Alors le fait est que
je suis pas sûr que tous nos cerveaux
réunis ça soi tellement plus intelligent
que deux trois cerveaux réunis. Enfin,
on le voit bien avec internet le pire
côtoi le meilleur. Mais bon voilà, une
machine enfin voilà une intelligence
artificielle des logiciels qui
permettrai de voilà d'avoir une
conscience de soi et cetera puis
finalement prendrait en charge la
planète et sa gestion et tout ce monde
très compliqué. On sait pas trop quoi
faire pour essayer de stabiliser notre
système bah ça serait pris en charge par
la machine pour faire ça. Moi j'ai pas
bien compris s'il y croyait s'il y
croyait pas. J'ai l'impression que il
est à la fois euh il joue sur ce terme
un peu de d'intelligence artificielle
mais en même temps il voilà il reconnaît
que l'intelligence artificielle forte
comme le comme le disent d'ailleurs
toute une série d'experts Ghanacia et
autres finalement c'est quelque chose on
n' pas le le début du commencement de du
moindre truc pour imaginer ça et que ce
qu'on sait faire effectivement c'est des
couches de réseaux neuronaux programmés
qui effectivement jouent furieusement
bien au go
et peuvent progresser très fortement sur
je sais pas recommander des des offres
commerciales vraiment super sympa en
fonction de votre niveau de navigation
et puis et puis faire de la de la
traduction automatique. Donc oui, OK,
mais voilà, passer à au stade supérieur
sur le mode attention, ça va être
Terminator enfin ou al faire attention à
ce que ça soit pas Terminator.
Voilà, j'ai pas encore réussi à
comprendre s'il y croyait ou s'il y
croyait pas. Et puis voilà, il y a ce
côté un peu
disons corn cornucopien au sens
qui profite de la corde d'abondance.
Voilà, qui et puis qui mais qui refuse
de voir les conséquences
environnementales parce que al je me
souviens avoir
avoir participé à des à des à des débats
parfois avec des des gens bien plus
truculants que Laurent Alexandre. Moi je
pense par exemple à un monsieur qui
s'appelle Jean Carvadou je pas alors je
je lui fais un peu de pub mais c'est pas
obligé d'acheter des bouquins et donc si
vousz un peu sur le mode ça y est les
écolos ils nous emmerdent ça commence à
bien faire en fait tout va bien alors
c'était du genre oui mais alors en
France la forêt progresse donc qu'est-ce
qu'on nous embête avec la déforestation
donc c'est des arguments un peu
fallacieux parce que bah oui ok la forêt
alors déjà tout dépend ce qu'on appelle
une forêt parce que quand on se promène
dans les landes bon pas sûr ça soit
vraiment de la super forêt avec un
maximum de biodiversité mais enfin Bon,
allez, admettons, soyons gentils, mais à
côté de ça, voilà, on a quand même des
problèmes avec d'autres zones où il y a
effectivement des forestations. Donc, il
y a il y a voilà, il y a il y a cette
espèce de négation de la situation qui
en me paraît quand même indéniable quoi.
Il pleut du plastique quoi. Donc bah
voilà, je sais pas ce que Laurent
Alexandre a à répondre à ça quoi. Est-ce
qu'il ni le fait qu'il pleut du
plastique ? Est-ce qu'il dit euh il
pleut du plastique mais c'est pas grave,
l'eau sera quand même potable parce que
les microparticules de plastique qui va
nous trouver une solution pour collecter
tout ça. Il y a des milliardaires qui
vont prendre leur argent pour faire des
bateaux qui collectent 5 tonnes de
plastique dans l'Atlantique.
Ouais. Alors ça c'est Oui. Alors ça
c'est la partie c'est plus que
Cornucopia ça. J'en ai parlé un peu
aussi dans
c'est l'économie. Ouais. Alors c'est moi
j'appelle ça l'économie réparatrice.
C'est c'est que en fait on n plus non se
enfin c'est la techno est tellement
formidable que non seulement on va
produire verre, on va être dans de
l'écologie industrielle, on va
ceux qui prétendent sauver la planète ne
sont pas des gens sérieux. C'est ça.
[rires]
De toute façon, qu'est-ce que ça veut
dire sauver la planète ? C'est encore
une autre question. Ce qu'il faut c'est
c'est sauver des conditions de voilà des
conditions de vie supportable et et
sympathiques pour la un maximum de
personnes. Enfin maximum je sais pas
pour les personnes qui sont su en tout
cas.
Alors les alors c'est pas que des
milliardaires qui veulent sauver la
planète par les il y a des il y a des
très sympathiques
des idées. Enfin voilà la nettoyage des
océans, c'est pas c'est pas des c'est
pas forcément des milliardaires, ils
peuvent contribuer mais bon voilà
plastique odyssée ou boyan slo et tout
c'est pas c'est pas des gens qui sont
issus de du grand capitalisme
californien ou américain.
Non, le problème c'est de se dire
qu'effectivement c'est possible et là
c'est là que ça devient difficile parce
que je je veux pas critiquer trop trop
fortement les enthousiasmes. Form enfin
je veux dire c'est voilà c'est mieux
d'essayer de travailler à nettoyer les
océans que de travailler à terraformer
Mars. Enfin ça me paraît plus utile et
plus sympathique. Le problème c'est que
jusqu'à quel point alors d'abord c'est
c'est affreusement inefficace.
On sait alors j'ai fait quelques calculs
à coup de millions de tonnes, je vais
pas vous les assainer ce soir, mais il
se trouve que même en nettoyant tous les
vortex océanique comme Boyan Slot le
propose, la majorité du plastique est au
fond. Donc les océans seront pas à
nouveau propres, ils vont rester très
très sales en dessous. On en en voit
évidemment beaucoup et et le et et
au-delà de l'inefficacité de la méthode
et du système, le problème c'est que ça
permet de se dédouiner de d'interrompre
la source en fait. washing.
Non, c'est pas du green washing mais
c'est mais les gens vont s'en emparer
pour dire bah vous voyez, il y a une
solution donc arrêtez, on peut continuer
à produire du plastique. Il y avait un
il y avait un article comme ça qui était
paru dans un journal où c'est la
journaliste se posait la question de
dire comment faire pour que en 2000 je
sais plus 50 je crois pour qu'en 2050 il
y ait il y ait pas plus de plastique que
de poissons dans les océans comment
faire alors et du coup cette
l'article embrayait très très vite sur
la question du nettoyage et des
meilleures techniques pour nettoyer et
non il y a que une seule méthode pour
qu'il y ait moins de plastique que de
poisson sont dans l'océan 2050. Enfin,
il y en a deux. La première, c'est
d'arrêter de produire du plastique en
quantité phénoménale et la deuxième,
c'est de moins surpêcher. Donc, mais
voilà. Et donc, en se disant on va
nettoyer, on est toujours dans la
logique de dire je passe après. Or en
fait non, c'est toujours tellement plus
simple, tellement plus efficace,
tellement plus rapide, tellement peu
coûteux d'ailleurs, moins coûteux de
d'agir à la source, de réduire à la
source. Donc d'où les questions
effectivement de sobriété, d'éventuelle
interdiction. Est-ce que notre économie,
[grognement] Est-ce que nos nos cerveaux
même ont été habitués à ça ? Non, on va
y avoir la il y a eu 40 ans ou 50 ans de
d'endctrinement par la publicité en
activant les zones du cerveau les plus
primitives pour déclencher des des
comportements d'achat. euh le côté euh
ça va vite, on a une société qui va
vite, on consomme vite euh et puis après
on jette vite. Est-ce que la population
est capable de de de d'inverser la
pression, de partir dans l'autre sens ?
Et notre économie
est-elle suffisamment résiliente pour
rentrer vers ce changement de paradigme
?
Alors là, on a ouvert quatre portes là.
Donc je vais essayer de les traiter les
unes derrière les autres, mais
évidemment, il y a rien d'évident tout
ça. La première chose, c'est de se dire
est-ce que les gens sont prêts à ça ?
Donc ça, pour moi, ça ouvre la question
de l'utopie euh
euh du consomm acteur. On va faire ça
pour ça. Alors là, à nouveau euh je
jette la pierre à personne et tout ce
qui se passe, toutes les initiatives qui
peuvent tourner autour de ça sont
zéro déchets.
Génial. Non mais génial. les
recycleries, ressourceries, les circuits
courts, les associations qui se battent
contre telle ou
ça sur une jambe de bois.
Bah oui,
en première paire, bim.
Oui. Non mais malheureusement oui.
C'estàd que en fait c'est sans doute une
couche nécessaire, cette prise de
conscience personnelle, familiale et
cetera. Mais le fait est que voilà, on
sait queon vit dans une économie qui est
une économie poussée, hein. Ça, on le
sait depuis à minima depuis John Kennet
Galbr nouvel état industriel qui
explique très bien que en gros soit vous
avez un marché pour les acteurs privés,
il faut faire de la pub et il faut
contrôler le marché parce que vous
poussez les produits de vent et que le
coût de développement des produits fait
que vous pouvez pas vous planter sur la
quantité de vente, soit vous vendez au
complexe militar industriel parce que
c'est des coûts de développement très
fort et voilà. Et donc ailleurs si la
silicone vallet et la silicone vallet,
c'est parce que derrière Boston
Dynamics, vous avez l'armée des
États-Unis qui est là pour être capable
de dire "Fabriquez-moi des robots
fantasin du futur et c'est pas grave, je
peux mettre 10 ans à fond perdu mais ça
m'intéresse." Voilà. Donc le consomme
acteur super mais insuffisant parce que
voilà à chaque fois que
une personne va aller faire réparer son
ordinateur dans un repair café ou
installer Linux je sais pas quoi parce
que ça consomme moins de ressources sur
le microprocesseur et ben Foxcon va
avoir sorti et vomi je sais pas combien
de de centaines de milliers
d'exemplaires de nouveaux ordinateurs
qui viendront alimenter les déchets
d'Afrique de l'Ouest ou du Pakistan à
chaque fois [grognement] que il y a une
amap sympa et puis qu'on va avoir sauvé
quelques quelques hectares de terre
agricole parce que je sais pas quoi
l'association terre de lien aura réussi
à racheter les terres du petit maréchet
pour l'installer. On aura bétonné je ne
sais combien d'hectares.
On a quand même construit 500000 m² de
nouvelles surface commerciales en France
en 2017. Sont les derniers chiffres que
j'avais trouvé. Il y a pas de raison que
2018 a été particulièrement difficile si
l'on aurait entendu le les les gens se
plaindre.
Donc 500000 m², je c'est c'est
gigantesque. Enfin, est-ce qu'on a
encore besoin de surface commerciale
avec on a on a le pays qui est plus
grand nombre de mètres carrés, je crois
de de surface commerciale par habitant
et on continue à bétonner. Il faut
savoir que tout à l'heure, on parlait
des exponentiels avec les les
civilisations galactiques. Même sans
exponentiel, il y a quand même des trucs
qui vont être difficiles à maintenir
de de manière de manière tendantielle.
Les vieux.
Alors non, je pensais d'abord à l'ar
l'artificialisation des sols. D'accord.
Donc aujourd'hui, c'est 1 % du
territoire
de l'ordre donc de un département
français qui qui est artificialisé tous
les 7 à 10 ans. D'accord ? Plutôt 7 ans
maintenant. C'est plutôt d' 10 il y a
quelques quelques décennies. Maintenant,
on est plutôt tous les 7 ans. Donc comme
alors il y a des incertitudes, mais on
va dire pour faire très très simple, on
va dire qu'il y a 10 % ou un peu plus du
territoire qui est artificialisé en
France. 90 % il suffit de faire 90 x 7 x
93. dans 600 ans. Si on continue à
bétonner au même rythme qu'on bétonne
aujourd'hui, la France, pour ne prendre
que cet exemple, ça fera la planète
Trentor, hein, le centre de l'Empire
galactique dans la trilogie d'Asimov,
fondation, quoi. C'est entièrement
artificialisé, couvert de béton et
d'acier. Voilà. Est-ce que on peut
imaginer que la France va être un jour
comme ça ? Réponse : Non, évidemment,
c'est pas possible. Donc ça veut dire
qu'à un moment la tendance va s'arrêter,
va devoir s'arrêter. la courbe va devoir
s'inverser. Pourquoi ? Comment ? À cause
de quelle loi ou de quel Voilà, donc il
y a il y a des choses comme ça qui qui
sont pas possible. Donc alors sur les
vieux, oui, là on ouvre la question
démographique, c'est une autre porte, on
laisse de côté pour l'instant, on
l'ouvre après peut-être mais toujours
sur le consommer acteur. Donc moi, je
pense que la la les voilà, on a cette
couche indispensable sans doute de prise
de conscience et haute, mais
majoritairement ça peut pas ça peut pas
venir de ça. C'est pas que c'est
bullshit, mais ça peut pas
Je me fais l'avocat du diable. Ça peut
pas être suffisant. C'est impossible.
C'est impossible. C'est impossible. Il a
on est il y a des marchés de niche des
trucs. Oui. On va boycotter et on va
c'est c'est un peu la stratégie de
Greenpeace d'ailleurs, c'est de dire je
vais aller chercher celui qui est au
top, celui qui est côté, celui que ça va
emmerder, que je le boycotte et cetera,
je vais agir sur lui pour ensuite de
transformer l'ensemble de la société.
Mais ça va être ça c'est c'est voilà ça
va ça va s'il fallait déployer l'énergie
d'un d'un boycotte ou d'une opération
qui va se passer un peu médiatisé je
sais pas quoi à l'ensemble des problèmes
qu'il faut régler aujourd'hui je dire
c'est c'est voilà c'est pas possible la
chair of voice de de des des
associations environnementales ne ne n'y
suffira pas il faudrait passer à plein
temps faire des des je sais pas quoi des
des articles et des trucs alors il y a
l'huile de palme d'un côté les
ressources l'exploitation des gens non
c'est c'est c'est vraiment à À mon avis,
c'est compliqué. Al après, il y a il y a
qu'est-ce qu'il y a d'autre après ça ?
Il y a la question alors on parlait tout
à l'heure du cerveau était un peu en
vi sur les vieux juste avant
sur les vieux.
La question démographique.
Alors la question démographique, moi je
constate
d'abord
sujeti.
Ouais. Ah bah faut l'aborder faut
l'aborder avec délicatesse. Oui, ça
c'est évident. Je constate juste très
factuellement que il y a une réémergence
de ce débat
du côté maltusien.
Du côté maltusien. Oui. Alors maltusien
au sens néaltusien mais sans on va on va
le mettre sans péj sans péjoratif hein,
on va dire parce que les les William
Vog, Fairfield Osborne, Airlich et
compagnie se déclarait se déclarent se
déclarait néaltusien mais sans aucune
voilà en disant on a remis au goût de
jour la pensée de Maltus parce que mais
il le prenait pas de manière négative.
Ensuite, le mot maltusien a été un petit
peu amalgamé
voilà par des par un certain nombre de
de de personnes, voilà, de d'idéologues
en disant "Bah voilà, dès que vous
voulez restreindre quelque chose, la
consommation de ressources, je sais pas
quoi, vous êtes maltusien." Non non, on
peut aller vers le toujours plus à
chaque fois. Donc voilà, si on prend
juste la question purement
démographique, voilà, il y a des gens
qui se déclarent néaltiens et qui ont
pas du tout peur de d'utiliser le terme.
On va voir ce que va donner ce ce débat,
mais moi, je constate que finalement
c'est voilà, on [grognement] c'est 40
ans plus tard
dans les années 70, c'était un débat qui
était assez vif, même au niveau des des
sommets internationaux,
l'ONU sur l'environnement et cetera. Et
en fait, ça a été gommé à à ces euh à
ces suptissements dans les années 80 90
2000. Et ça réapparaît effectivement
maintenant, mais sauf que entre-temps,
on est des milliards en plus. Alors,
c'est délicat parce que c'est des c'est
des fondamentaux.
Enfin, bon, d'abord, il y a évidemment
toute la charge culturelle, religieuse,
enfin bon, sur laquelle il faut aller
c'est encore plus prudemment. Donc onira
pas soir, enfin pas avec moi, mais
euh
alors Philippe.
Non non mais oui bon enfin je veux dire
je veux pas prendre une fatouie non plus
quoi. Donc euh
attention de pas m'envoyer mon tapis là.
Euh non
disons qu'il y a des il y a des il y a
des des tendances lourdes qui sont ce
qu'elles sont. C'estàd que si les
profils de population actuels qu'on peut
avoir un certain nombre de pays font que
de toute manière le le coût est parti.
Donc il y a des choses même si on veut
avoir des actions extrêmement
volontaristes sur l'éducation des
filles, sur le développement sur un
système de retraite qu'on pourrait
installer ici ou là et cetera pour
essayer de de de faire que la transition
démographique se fasse partout.
Il faut un coup de main des religieux.
Bah oui, ça ferait ça ferait pas de mal.
Après, je sais pas comment est-ce que on
peut effectivement faire évoluer des des
des dogmes millénaires. Euh oui,
finalement là-dessus, on s'est peut-être
fait ou alors en tout cas les
circonstances font qu'on va évoluer.
Bon, je sais pas si c'est possible mais
en fait ce que ce que m'a toujours enfin
ce que je trouve assez euh assez
intéressant sur ce débat sur la
démographie, c'est qu'en fait c'est
toujours un débat sur la question des
naissances.
Pourquoi on a pas de débat sur
Pourquoi on a pas de débat sur l'action
de l'allongement de liquider les vieux ?
Voilà, exactement. Alors, je propose pas
de liquider les vieux mais voilà, il y a
aujourd'hui il y a en tout cas il y a
des choses qui émergent. Je voyais
l'autre jour, il y avait un il y avait
un il y avait un un sondage en Belgique
par sur la question de est-ce qu'on
interrompt ou pas un certain nombre de
soin palliatif
voilà de soins palliatifs à partir d'un
certain âge et cetera et en fait les les
chiffres étaient déjà assez surprenants.
Donc ça prouve que les choses bougent. B
je voulais on arrête.
[grognement]
Voilà, je sais plus combien c'était
exactement mais il y avait il y avait en
tout cas c'était significatif, c'était
assez assez intéressant. Donc la
communauté de fackl je crois de souvenir
c'était plus de 70 %.
Je sais pas s' était majoritaire moi de
mémoire non ça l'était pas mais c'était
en tout cas très très significatif.
Voilà ça va fa checker tranquillement.
Voilà donc le le donc effectivement
alors dans le débat transhumaniste, je
trouve c'est intéressant de de
complètement passer sous sous silence
cette question là parce que finalement
on se on repousse l'âge de la mort. Bon,
très bien formidable. Alors, c'est
plutôt la Silver économie version
euh euh mourroir du 4e âge
sur lesquels il y a un bon retour sur
investissement pour les les gens qui
investissent dans des épades. Donc bon,
est-ce que ça est-ce que ça ça fait des
vies globalement plus heureuses ou pas ?
C'est c'est une question. Il y a tout un
jeu aussi sur cette question de
l'augmentation de l'espérance de vie
parce que d'ailleurs même Laurent
Alexandre pour le coup se se trompe
parce qu'il dit [grognement] il dit
voilà on l'espérance de vie progresse de
de de
9 mois tous les ans de 3 mois tous les
ans. Donc finalement à chaque année qui
passe on vieillit que de 9 mois parce
que je repousse de 3 mois ça marche pas
du tout comme ça. Enfin l'espérance de
vie c'est une notion mathématique c'est
l'espérance de vie à la naissance et
malheureusement tous les an tous les
années qui passent je me rapproche d'un
an de ma mort. Ça pour le coup, on sait
que c'est physiquement indéniable. Donc
voilà, c'est c'est les enfants hein.
C'est les Télomè.
Les
Télomè,
c'est quoi ça ?
Ça vous parle pas ? On vous fera un
cours plus tard.
Ah ouais, carrément. Non non, je suis
perdu là. Euh voilà. Donc moi, je pense
que effectivement il y a il y a il doit
[grognement] y avoir une question autour
de ça. Est-ce qu'on veut
est-ce qu'on veut continuer à repousser
l'âge de la mort ? Est-ce que finalement
c'est c'est un on repousse juste l'âge
de la mort ou est-ce qu'on repousse
l'âge où on vit en bonne santé ? C'est
quand même parce que voilà la prévalence
de d'Alzheimer et autres dans les
[grognement] dans les maisons du 4e âge
donne pas forcément très envie.
Euh voilà et que c'est pas juste une
question de Natalie ou de
vieillir avec une petite retraite h
ou de vieillir avec une petite retraite
dans un climat économique où l'inflation
règne.
Oui. Alors c'est là pour le coup euh
Laurent Alexandre il est assez affreux
parce qu'il dit on a le choix finalement
entre un ÉPAD où on change deux couches
par jour et un ÉPAD où on change six
couches par jour. Donc c'est assez mais
oui évidemment là il y a plusieurs
manières de vieillir en fonction de son
pouvoir d'achat. C'est c'est bien
évident. Et d'ailleurs, c'est pas pour
rien que c'est plutôt les milliardaires
californiens qui s'intéressent à en fait
de repousser l'âge de la mort. C'est pas
forcément des ouvriers qui ont passé
leur vie à se casser les reins et le dos
et qui arrivent à 62 ans complètement
cassé et qui qui ont plusieurs années
d'espérance de vie en moins que que
[grognement] les cadres. Donc voilà, on
sait bien qu'il y a une injustice
l'injustice se prolonge jusqu'à jusqu'au
dernier instant de de vie. Ouais.
Sinon, vous êtes plus vous êtes en
accord avec Laurent Alexandre sur tous
les autres points.
Non, mais là on va attendre enfin la
prochaine fois. C'est ça. [rires]
On va passer aux questions internet.
Question très intéressante. Comment
fait-on la différence entre une avancée
technologique et un progrès
technologique ?
Bah c'est difficile à faire au point que
si j'en crois Étienne Kling vous aviez
reçu il y a quelques mois de ça
justement on ne on n'ose plus parler de
progrès, on parle d'innovation
et donc on est dans l'innovation
technologique. Alors après euh on va
tomber très vite dans le discours un peu
standard et lénifiant sur le mode bah la
technologie est neutre et ça dépend ce
qu'on en fait mon bon monsieur. Alors le
couteau, bah vous pouvez l'utiliser pour
couper du saucisson ou vous pouvez
l'utiliser pour pour
garder votre voisin. Et en fait voilà,
on sait que ça marche pas comme ça. Même
si Openheimer essayé de nous faire le
coup avec sa bombe, la bombe nucléaire.
Excusez-moi, je savais pas qu'on allait
pouvoir faire enfin je savais pas qu'on
allait utilisé comme ça. Non, on sait
que la technologie n'est jamais neutre.
Ça c'est bon, ça a été un peu montré et
qu'on ne peut pas on ne peut pas séparer
le mésusage du bon usage. C'est c'est ça
qui est terrible. Donc toute avancée
technologique, il y aura toujours des
choses bien et des choses moins bien.
Donc c'est vrai pour internet, c'est
vrai pour sans doute les big data. Alors
évidemment, on on va en général les
turiféraires de la technique vont
toujours nous nous mettre en avant
plutôt justement les choses plutôt
sympathiques. Alors voilà, c'est
toujours
contre le con, le cancer.
Voilà. Donc typiquement la médecine,
c'est les applications médicales sont le
cheval de 3 à peu près systématique
parce que voilà, confiez toutes vos
données à Google et et on va on va
effectivement pouvoir faire de la
détection préventive.
Euh voilà donc euh et c'est très très
dur de
c'est très très dur de contester ça. Je
me souviens que quand on avait commis
euh euh
avec Harili euh notre livre sur le le
désastre de l'école numérique, voilà, on
nous avait dit euh ben attendez vous
donc vous voulez pas que les qu' les
cours soient numérisés, alors les
enfants hospitalisés en fait peuvent pas
rattraper leur cours à cause de vous
quoi. on était vraiment des monstres
parce que on allait empêcher les enfants
hospitalisés de de suivre les cours à
distance quoi. Donc voilà, très vite on
va tomber dans ce genre de de choses.
Donc progrès technologique, bah il
faudrait voilà revenir à la notion de à
la notion de progrès. C'est c'est pas
facile.
[grognement]
C'est pas facile parce que voilà,
l'historique est pas est pas forcément
terrible. C'est-à-dire qu'on voit bien
que
on voit bien que alors les économistes
même les économistes les plus obtus
reconnaissent que il y a cette courbe un
peu bonheur PIB là qui finit par stagner
là qui monte très vite au début hein.
Quand on est vraiment miséreux bah c'est
c'est difficile d'être heureux hein.
Peut-être c'est possible. Enfin c'est
quand même
C'est quoi être miséreux ? C'est moins
de 5 dollars par jour, moins d'un dollar
par jour. Bah non, moi j'ai pas de
j'arrive pas à à me faire assez
statistiques euh
chiffrées de la Banque mondiale ou autre
parce qu'en fait ça ça dépend de ce qui
est euh ça dépend ce qui de ce qui est
monétisé. C'est-à-dire qu'en fait, il y
a eu voilà, il y a des il y a des le
développement, ça a consisté aussi à
transformer une économie qui était une
économie familiale
euh de d'autoproduction, de partage en
une économie euh plus merchandisée. Et
donc forcément à ce moment-là, le manque
d'argent fait que voilà donc c'est
toujours un peu difficile parce que
voilà, si je suis propriétaire de mon
logement
et de mon champ et que je je produis ce
que de quoi nourrir ma famille, j'ai un
problème quand j'ai besoin d'aller
monétiser enfin quand j'ai un problème
médical par exemple et que je vais
devoir trouver quelqu'un qui accepte pas
d'être payé en pomme de terre ou en ép
de maïs. Mais si à part ce genre de cas
finalement je serais pas forcément
malheureux. Et de la même manière,
finalement aujourd'hui euh je peux vivre
avec le SMIC mais être propriétaire du
logement que on laissé mes parents où je
peux vivre avec le SMIC et être
locataire et je pense que c'est pas tout
à fait la même vie et d'ailleurs je peux
vivre avec le SMIC à Paris ou vivre avec
le SMIC à euh dans le lotaron et sans
doute c'est pas tout à fait non plus la
même chose. Donc c'est très difficile
pour moi de voilà enfin je pense que
c'est compliqué de mettre vraiment une
limite mais en tout cas c'est sûr que il
y a voilà les revenus sont relativement
bien corrélés avec les courbes de alors
je sais pas s'il parlent de bonheur mais
enfin en tout cas de voilà de de de
d'aisance
voilà et ensuite très très vite alors
très vite je sais pas c'est peut-être à
20000 et quelques dollars ou euros j'en
sais rien par an
les courbes se mettent à stagner c'est
finalement le on n'est pas plus heureux
au Qatar ou aux États-Unis que en
Finlande, au Danemark ou en Espagne.
Donc c'est la preuve qu'il y a un moment
où en fait on on on stagne un petit peu
et la raison elle est assez simple
parceologique
que que tu as abordé tout à l'heure sur
dire finalement on a le cerveau qui est
qui est qui est construit d'une certaine
manière et puis à chaque fois qu'on nous
met un truc sous les yeux, on a envie de
le consommer ce qui est à peu près vrai.
Mais le on sait que le désir il est
avant tout mimétique. On on désire pas,
on désire rien a priori seul. On désire
ce que désirent les autres, on désire ce
qu'on a vu chez les autres. Donc c'est
avant tout la consommation des autres
qui qui qui va construire les schémas de
consommation
de de chaque de chaque personne. Et
c'est voilà et ça on sait que ça ça
ruisselle pour le coup. On sait que la
consommation la consommation
ostentatoire des des classes les plus
aisées va comme ça descendre tout au
long de la des des différentes
différentes couches sociales et
différents continents
et évidemment tout ça ça traverse les
couches sociales et ça traverse les
géographies mais on sait que maintenant
enfin c'est très on peut plus vraiment
parler de pays du nord pays du sud pays
développé pas développé parce queil y a
aussi ces classes moyennes émergentes où
c'est où c'est cette classe ultra
mondialisée et et aisée un petit peu
partout mais voilà donc moi je pense pas
que enfin c'est vrai évidemment
compliqué puisquon est dans une logique
un peu de de de monde un peu
propagande voilà propagande commerciale
alors qui est très dure à démonter
évidemment parce que elle est bien
installée et puis elle arrange beaucoup
de monde et il y a beaucoup de gens de
bonne foi à mon avis partout dans le
système c'estàd que je pense qu'il y a
plein de gens très intelligents qui
seraient classés comme il faut dans le
le système de QID de de Laurent
Alexandre qui sont je sais pas quoi des
au fonctionnaires
cadre dans des entreprises dirigeants
d'entreprises et autres qui on envie de
faire quelque chose qui voit bien que le
système voilà en mode tendantiel
justement bon la planète Trentor bon
c'est c'est sympa dans les bouquins de
science-fiction des années 60 mais à
part ça pas forcément mais qui ont du
mal à à trouver de des chemins
parce que voilà quel quel PDG convaincu
d'une grande entreprise pourrait décider
décidé de de faire un rakyri sur son
chiffre d'affaires pour dire on va plus
construire que des objets durables. Donc
au lieu de faire des ferés qui durent 2
ans, on va faire des fer qui durent 10
ans ou 20 ans. Donc chiffre d'affaires
potentiellement divisé par 10. Les
premiers à à le débarquer ce garsl ça
sera même pas les actionnaires, ça sera
les employés, les syndicats.
Les emplettes sont les emplois. Donc ça
c'est c'est compliqué. Donc il y a il y
a des exemples. Il y a des exemples.
Alors pour pas les citer,
Sebouinex a qui qui a a accès vraiment
sa sa communication ses ces derniers
temps sur la question de la
réparabilité. Donc c'est c'est vraiment
bien. C'est un c'est un beau discours.
Nous nos objets, ils sont durables, ils
sont réparables, on a des réseaux de
réparateur, on va garantir les pièces et
cetera.
Donc c'est on va pas jeter la pierre à
cette initiative mais finalement ils le
font pas pour diviser leur chiffre
d'affaires par 10. Ils le font pour et
pourquoi pas euh euh h euh euh des
regagner des parts de marché sur
peut-être des choses qui sont construits
dans des pays euh euh en low cost et
cetera qui ont pris des parts de marché
au made in France historiquement. Donc
on va surjouer un peu le made in France,
c'est super. Et puis quelque part, on va
essayer de fidéliser le consommateur
disant "Bah tiens, vous m'avez acheté
euh une yaourtière, ça vous dirait pas
une machine à pain, elle aussi réparable
et durable." Donc on va compter sur un
espèce de niche marketing qui va
permettre de se développer. Aucune
aucune société, aucune entreprise va
dire "Moi, je réduis mon chiffre
d'affaires." Aucun état va dire "Je
réduis mon PIB parce que au PIB est
grosso modo, c'est pas qu'il y a une
espèce de facile,
on est cuit, on est cuit. [rires]
Il y a pas une espèce de cuit
[raclement de gorge] ?
Non, je sais pas si on est cuit. Alors,
on va y venir après. Ça c'est euh non.
Pourquoi ? Pourquoi un état peut pas
réduire son PIB ? Parce qu'on voit pas
envie de le faire. pas parce qu'ils ont
une fascination du PIV, mais parce que
il y a un service de la dette et que
grosso modo bah il y a à peu près enfin
service de la dette et puis les il faut
payer des salaires et cetera et que on
va pas voilà, on sait que à peu près bah
les entrées les rentrées d'impôts TVA et
autres, c'est à peu près corrélé au PIB.
Donc si le PIB monte de 2 %, c'est
mieux. Bon après il se trouve que dans
les chiffres de PIB, il y a plein de
trucs un petit peu frelatés dont on
pourrait rediscuter mais qui prendrait
une séance complète.
Euh alors, est-ce qu'on est cuit ? Euh
c'est qui on d'abord ? Voilà. Donc bon,
moi j'ai il y a une notion que j'ai
beaucoup euh que j'aime beaucoup, c'est
euh qui a été euh inventé quasi je pense
enfin me semble-t-il par euh Daniel
Poly, euh spécialiste des
ressources euh aliotiques, des poissons,
des stocks de poisson. c'est un
biologiste canadien euh et qui parle de
de décalage de points de référence
shifting baseline. Bon et ça c'est pour
moi c'est le le la clé de lecture
majeure de du monde. Euh enfin je
j'exagère sans doute un peu, je
simplifie mais je trouve que c'est
vraiment un un un
modèle qui très puissant. Donc en gros,
pour faire simple, on va dire c'est
parti en fait sur la logique de dire les
scientifiques devaient émettre une
opinion sur le quelle était la quantité
admissible de pêche pour chacune des
pêcheries hein. Il doit ce qui permet
ensuite de d'aboutir sur des quotas de
pêche et cetera. Bon pour pour préserver
la ressource. Donc quelle est la
quantité maximum admissible chaque année
qu'on peut effectivement aller prélever
? Et ça ça dépend d'un des stocks, ça
dépend de d'un certain nombre
d'interaction entre espèces et cetera.
Et en fait ce qu'il a montré au début,
enfin ce qu'il a un petit peu exprimé
intuitivement, c'était que chaque
génération de de scientifiques qui
arrivaient sur le marché, si je puis
dire, à qui on allait demander son avis
au cours de sa carrière sur est-ce que
le stock de Merl, de machin, de sol et
est surpêché ou pas surpêché.
En fait, il arrivait dans la carrière
avec un une référence, un point de
référence qui était le moment où enfin
le moment où il est arrivé dans sa
carrière et qu'il il allait ensuite
dérouler toute sa carrière sur la base
de ce point de référence qu'il avait lui
connu en arrivant en démarrant et que ce
point de référence c'était pas le même
que la génération précédente ou que la
génération suivante. Et après il a
élargi un peu ça notamment ils ont fait
des recherches sur des photos par
exemple de de trophées de pêche en
montrant que finalement le grand-père,
le pêcheur, ce qu'il appelait un gros
poisson pour une espèce neée, bah
c'était ça et puis le père c'était ça et
le fils c'était ça et et qu'en fait
voilà comme on surpêchait les stocks,
bah au bout d'un moment en fait il y
avait de moins en moins de poissons et
qu'ils étaient de plus en plus petits.
Et d'ailleurs on descend dans ce qu'on
appelle le niveau trophique,
c'est-à-dire que on ne mangeait que des
super prédateurs et puis maintenant on
va pêcher du CR parce que il commence à
y avoir un peu moins de trucs audessus.
Bon et ce qui est
absolument puissant avec cette réflexion
là, c'est que ça s'applique à tout.
Ça s'applique évidemment à la question
de la biodiversité en premier lieu. Donc
tous ces articles absolument effrayants
sur
les x dizaines de % de d'oiseaux en
moins de papillon de grands mammifères
de et cetera. C'est par rapport à une
référence qui peut être alors il y a 10
ans, il y a 12 ans pour les
chauves-souris, il y a 30 ans pour les
mammifères. Enfin, ça dépend des études
scientifiques qui sortent, mais on
pourrait aussi le comparer il y a 100
ans, ou il y a 200, ou il y a 500, ou il
y a 1000, ou il y a 10000 avant la avant
l'extinction de la mégaphone euh du
playistocè. Enfin, faut dire hein, il y
avait des hippopotames nains à Chypre en
Corse, il y avait des Lions en Grèce et
dans toute l'Afrique du Nord. C'est
toujours des hippopotamins encore.
Ah alors peut-être oui voilà d'une autre
d'un autre type. [rires]
Mais voilà donc et c'est donc on et ça
se décale et en fait finalement euh moi
j'ai connu plus de papillons et
d'insectes que mes enfants quand j'étais
petit, quand j'étais jeune. Bon c'est le
fameux cette fameuse histoire du du
pare-brise qu'il fallait nettoyer au
mois de juin quand on avait fait
quelques centaines de kilomètres et
maintenant il est tout propre machin.
Les spécialistes en coefficient CX des
voitures, elles sont quand même plus
profilées qu'avant, donc elles tapent un
petit peu moins les insectes que dans
les années 7080 mais enfin quand même,
il semblerait bien qu'il y ait quand
même moins beaucoup moins d'insectes.
La grille de radiateur, elle a pas été
profilée, hein.
Oui. Alors voilà, après on nettoyait
moins la grille de radiateur, on passait
surtout le pare-brise pour la
visibilité. Mais bon,
une voiture.
Ah bah carrément oui bien sûr.
Vous avez quoi comme voiture ?
Ah non, est-ce que j'ai une voiture
aujourd'hui ? J'ai pas j'ai plus de
voiture. Non, j'ai plus voiture. Mais
bon, c'est facile de pas avoir de
voiture. Voilà, on empreinte, on loue.
Enfin, non,
tu peux habiter en creuse.
Absolument. Et je jetterai sûrement pas
la la pierre aux gens qui ont besoin de
leur voiture et qui sont dans la dans la
mobilité contrainte, c'est clair.
D'ailleurs, moi ce que je propose, c'est
bien une sortie de la civilisation de la
voiture, mais pas une sortie immédiate
parce que elle est pas possible. Par
contre, on pourrait d'un claquement de
doigts ou presque réduire très fortement
la consommation de de de carburant des
des voitures. Il suffit juste qu'elle
soit plus légère, moins puissante mettre
plus ou ou de mettre plusieurs personnes
à l'intérieur.
Oui, mais là on tombe malheureusement
dans le dans l'effet rebond euh pour
partie. Alors là, sur le covoiturage,
alors on a glissé, on finira sur
Shifting Baseline après, c'est pas
grave. Bon euh on le parque euh le le
covoiturage, il y a deux types de
covoiturage. On pourrait dire un
covoiture.
Voiturage à la cube.
Alors ouais, il y a non, le mieux c'est
covoiturage Kinshasa pour
Taxi Brousse.
Ouais, c'est en fait le truc où il y a
même des gens à l'extérieur quoi. Donc
c'est c'est vraiment c'est vraiment bien
optimisé quoi. C'est malgré ça, il y a
des embouteillages plétoriques. Mais bon
euh une ville très étendue, très bon.
Congo Kinshasa. Ouais. Non non non, je
parlais je parlais là de de des modèles
de covoiturage dans un pays comme la
France. Il y a du covoiturage de longue
distance et puis il y a du covoiturage
de courte distance pour le les trajets
domicile travail. Sur le covoiturage
domicile travail, ce qui est compliqué
aujourd'hui, c'est de réussir à bah le
faire tous les jours d'abord parce que
ça peut être plus contraignant d'un
point de vue d'organisation donc pour
les personnes qui le font. Bon, mais
surtout, c'est difficile de trouver des
plateformes qui arrivent à se mettre
là-dessus parce que c'est difficile de
monétiser la relation entre les futurs
covoitureurs parce que une fois qu'ils
sont connus et qu'ils vont prendre tous
les jours la voiture ensemble, ils vont
pas payer tous les jours le site. Voilà,
donc il y a du coup des réflexions, ça a
évolué aujourd'hui sur la question de
dire finalement est-ce qu'il y a pas
presque un service public est-ce qu'il
faut pas qu'il voilà de cooiturage enfin
qui permettent de mettre des gens en
relation pour covoiturer tous les jours
ou alors bon voilà des acteurs privés
qui pourraient être subvention rebond de
on nous propose
alors par contre donc celui-là bon
l'effet rebond sur celui-là il peut y en
avoir un qui esserait de dire euh je
peux je peux me mettre plus loin je peux
habiter plus loin de mon travail puisque
jusqu'au voiture ça me coûte moins cher
mais enfin bon avant d'en arriver là je
pense que on a un peu de marge et qu'il
y un un véritable gisement de
covoiturage du quotidien. Le covoiturage
de longue distance à mon avis pour le
coup et là ça ça perturbe un peu tous
les tous les sociologues et tous les
gens qui travaillent sur sur ces sujets.
Et là, il y a un véritable effet rebond.
C'est-à-dire que les trois les trois
personnes qui sont dans la voiture et
qui vont faire un trajet, bah il y en a
un, il prenait le train, il y en a un
c'est pas cher. Donc finalement, je fais
un aller-retour. Donc la l'offre,
l'efficacité va créer de la de la
demande supplémentaire, l'offre moins
chère. Euh et puis le 3è peut-être bien
qu'il fait l'aller-retour aussi plus
souvent parce qu'il a la contribution
économique des autres. Donc en fait au
global le covoiturage longue distance
n'a pas forcément enfin on n'en sait
rien en fait parce que c'est on n' pas
de point de référence, on sait pas
calculer mais en tout cas le nombre de
litres de qui sortent des raffineries
chaque année pour le coup lui il a pas
trop bougé donc il y a pas d'effet de
covoiturage. Donc euh voilà donc non moi
je pense que voilà c cet effet rebond il
est il est très difficile à éviter. il
est euh historiquement toute le à chaque
fois qu'il y a eu des techn C'est ça
aussi qui crée le la qui rend le
discours cornucopien de base un petit
peu un petit peu difficile à avaler,
c'est qu'à chaque fois qu'il y a eu de
l'efficacité qui a été amenée, alors là,
on parle bien de technologies qui vont
être plus efficaces, je vais pouvoir
chauffer mon logement sans avec moins de
de consommation énergétique ou
d'émission de gaz à effet de serre et
cetera. Je vais avoir du numérique. La
Smart City va me faire euh progresser
sur la manière de de de d'éviter les
gâchis, de mettre les gens ensemble, les
embouteillages avec les voitures
autonomes et cetera, tout ça. En fait
non, à chaque fois il y a eu un effet
rebond. Alors cet effet rebond, il est
pour partie, on pourrait dire
démographique aussi pour revenir au
débat qu'on avait tout à l'heure. Oui,
le fait d'être un petit peu plus
nombreux à chaque fois ça ça fait
développer la consommation à à iso
consonsommation par personne mais c'est
aussi la consommation par personne qui
augmente, c'est clair.
Question internet. Comment
expliquez-vous qu'on arrive à une
croyance dans la technologie comme une
croyance divine alors que [grognement]
la science semblait s'opposer à Dieu et
aux croyances ?
Ah, c'est une bonne question. Euh c'est
quoi ?
C'est les lobby ? C'est le ce qu'on a
mis dans la tête des gens. On va aller
tous dans l'espace, ça va nous sauver.
C'est le nouveau dieu.
Bah disons que oui, peut-être que
peut-être que le fait d'avoir un dieu
qui qui surveille un peu au-dessus ce
qui se passe, ça ça oblige à garder des
limites. Et quand on a alors j'ai pour
le meilleur et pour le pire, hein, je je
suis moi-même furieusement hâté.
Pas d'amine imaginaire,
hein.
Toujours pas d'amis imaginaire. Non,
ça va peut-être venir avec l'âge, mais
on verra.
Souvent, ça arrive avec l'âge.
Voilà. [grognement] Euh
donc le le
je pense qu'il y a alors en même temps
c'est c'est c'est on pourrait dire oui,
c'est cet incroyable développement du
numérique, des technologies euh créer
cet emballement et cette ce côté
homodeous là, c'est génial. ça va être
et en même temps oui et non parce que
finalement on retrouve des textes où on
s'emballait autant il y a il y a un
siècle. Donc euh donc j'ai du mal à à
vraiment me faire une opinion là-dessus.
Je pense qu'on a besoin je pense qu'en
fait l'homme est rêveur.
Il est il a toujours été rêveur. Il il
avait besoin de Alors pourquoi est-ce
qu'il est rêveur ? Il est rêveur sans
doute génétiquement.
Euh plus le monde va mal, plus il a
besoin de rêver probablement. C'est on a
besoin de s'extraire du quotidien.
pour penser une vie meilleure. Alors, il
y a eu un moment, il y a eu un moment et
puis c'est encore je pense pas mal
d'actualités, c'est la vie meilleure,
c'est c'est pour après la mort. Donc ça
c'est la religion.
Et puis et puis on a aujourd'hui qui
vient compléter peut-être une certaine
désérance religieuse dans un certain
nombre de pays. Mais bon franchement
c'est pas non plus sans doute la
majorité sur terre aujourd'hui. Euh on a
effectivement une promesse de vie
meilleure euh à travers la technologie
et et pour moi c'est toujours un peu une
manière de s'extraire.
Pourquoi on croit à ça ? C'est une
manière de s'extraire du quotidien quoi.
Mais pourquoi est-ce que les gens
achètent des prestations
chez les croisiériste ? Après
pour les gens achètent des œufs au plat
sous plastique déjà cuit ? Pourquoi les
gens achètent des bananes déjà épluchées
? Pourquoi achètent les gens achètent
des oranges déjà épluchées sous
plastique ?
Ouais, c'est les gens sont c'est une
bonne question. Alors non, alors il y a
il y a je mettrai deux trucs différents.
Alors il y a des gens qui achètent des
produits bio sous plastique mais je
crois comprendre qu'en fait dans les
supermarchés
s'oblige un peu à emballer pour la pour
assurer la traçabilité de c'est bio,
c'est pas bio. Donc peut-être est-ce que
c'est une manière enfin est-ce qu'il y a
une autre manière de faire ? En tout cas
le petit légumier lui ou sur le marché
il savent voilà eux ils savent faire
mais non pourquoi ben c'est une toujours
un arbitrage avec le temps. L'impression
d'avoir toujours moins de temps, d'avoir
d'être dans un temps plus contraint. Euh
les gens s'emmerdent plus assez. En
fait, c'est ça, c'est l'effet Netflix et
et autres joyeusé. Donc on a toujours
l'impression de l'ensemble de de l'offre
à disposition euh et bien crée voilà
créer cette impression de manque de
temps. Ça c'est un peu enfin c'est
impimpression ou l'impression réelle
parce que ça le fait de de se déplacer
beaucoup plus et d'être dans des dans
des systèmes un peu contraints
embouteillage transport saturé fait que
voilà on est
on a on a cette impression
d'accélération et de manquer de temps.
Je crois que Armou Rosa a raconté ça
assez bien dans dans son dans son essai
accélération en allant même un peu plus
loin sur des des trucs assez assez
perturbants par exemple en disant
quand les je dis pas que c'est bien
attention parce que là Laurent Alexandre
va encore dire oh là là ça y est il veut
revenir au temps des grands-parents où
on arrachait les molaires avec la porte
euh quand on a par exemple un enfant qui
a reçoit un livre à Noël en 1940
en pas 40 c'est trop chargé pardon 50 et
ben il a un livre et puis voilà, il
ouvrait son livre peut-être et puis il
feuilletait tous les soirs le même livre
et puis finissait par connaître
l'histoire par cœur, je sais pas quoi
puis ça créait de l'imaginaire. Et puis
si vous mettez le même enfant en fait,
il a 150 livres possibles devant lui,
bah quelque part en fait vous avez
modifié son rapport au temp parce que
finalement devant les 150 livres qu'il y
a éventuellement à lire. Je sais pas si
les enfants lisent encore mais peut-être
mon exemple est pas bon mais enfin Trosa
prend cet exemple là bah finalement vous
avez l'impression de manque de temps
parce qu'en fait vous arrivez pas à lire
les 150 donc en fait c'est l'offre qui à
un moment crée aussi la sensation de
manque de temps.
On va parler de votre bouquin qui
s'appelle Le bonheur a été pour demain.
Ouais.
Euh vous dites dedans que la transition
doit doit se faire dans le bonheur ou
doit apporter plus de bonheur.
Ouais.
C'est pas un peu bisou nours ça ? C'est
c'est un peu [rires] genre
c'est pas plus bisous. J'écris ça dans
le train, j'étais avec mon parapluie, il
pleuvait.
On va apporter du bonheur. Non non,
c'est
business. C'est un business ça ou pas ?
Quand on reproche au prophète de malheur
de surfer sur un business ou c'est une
réelle prise de conscience ?
Non non, c'est un peu un en fait c'est
un pied de nez au départ. Je sais pas
trop si je dois si je dois raconter en
fait. Non, c'est c'est parce que il y a
il y a il y a tout un business d'édition
autour de des méthodes de développement
personnel.
Voilà, du bonheur et cetera. Et donc
voilà, ça m' j'ai ça m'amusait de de
mettre bonheur dans le titre pour un peu
faire pied nez à tout ça, tout en
expliquant très vite dans le premier
paragraphe que non, c'est pas une
méthode de développement personnel. Euh
[rires]
donc non, en fait je j'ai pas j'ai pas
la j'ai pas exactement la solution, mais
le le le titre, il est d'abord sur la
pourquoi l'imparfait était pour demain ?
parce que j'ai c'est pour revenir sur
toute cette question un petit peu
historique en disant attention c'est pas
la première fois qu'on nous fait le
cours sur le mode la technologie va tout
résoudre et va nous rendre plus heureux
et regardz un peu ce qu'on s'est raconté
il y a 10 ans, il y a 20 ans, il y a 100
ans. Certes, il y a des choses qui ont
bougé, certes, il y a la loi de mour et
les microprocesseurs, mais enfin ça
règle pas tout. Et il y a plein d'autres
choses qui se plein d'autres contraintes
qui se qui se mettent en place. Donc les
promesses d'aujourd'hui euh n'engagent
que ceux qui les tiennent. Euh voilà, ça
c'est pour le côté imparfait. Et ensuite
effectivement on peut rajouter "Et si le
bonheur était pour demain ?" Et là,
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire ?
Je reviens sur la question des shifting
baseline. C'està-dire que moi je suis
terrorisé par le fait qu'il y a beaucoup
moins de papillon mais mon fils
peut-être pas tant que ça et mon
petitfils s'il y en a un, il le sera
sans doute encore moins. C'est
malheureusement le décalage des points
de référence et ça se décale dans tous
les sens sur tous les domaines. Ça se
décale dans le sur la morale, sur la sur
le les les valeurs de la société. Enfin,
je voilà, c'est euh donc il y a il y a
une
on a finalement sur le confort
aujourd'hui bah voilà, on chauffe les
logements plus euh plus que dans les
années 70 sûrement. Si on regarde la
consommation par personne même avec des
des voitures qui étaient vraiment
pourries, enfin qui étaient pas optimisé
comme aujourd'hui avec des logements qui
étaient des passoirs énergétiques et
cetera, on consommait trois ou quatre
fois moins d'énergie dans les années 60
en France que que qu'aujourd'hui. Donc
il y a il y a donc cet effet rebond a
pas forcément je que créer du du bonheur
parce que effectivement dans les années
60 et 70 les gens étaient pas forcément
en moyenne si malheureux que ça sans
doute. Enfin, en tout cas, ça n'a pas
laissé dans l'imaginaire collectif euh
[grognement]
de de
un un moment de de c'était pas des
décennies particulièrement liberticides,
me semble-t-il. Enfin, en tout cas,
voilà. Donc on on est le ce décalage de
des points de référence qui nous a fait
accepter aussi des choses plus
difficiles. Alors l'effondrement de la
biodiversité,
on pourrait dire peut-être touche peu
d'entre nous peut-être, j'en sais rien.
Mais il y a d'autres choses qui sont
plus difficiles. Il y a plus
d'embouteillage, les transports sont
plus saturés, il y a plus de difficultés
peut-être à se loger que à acquérir son
logement, hein. manger correctement.
À manger correctement sans doute parce
que effectivement ça devient un sport de
combat sans doute pour trouver ce qu'il
faut et pour trouver le temps pour
préparer soi-même et cetera. Donc il y a
un vrai un vrai sujet là-dessus. Donc
voilà, les choses se les perceptions se
décalent et elles se décalent dans tous
les sens. C'est donc il me semble que
par exemple s'il fallait un moment
peut-être moins chauffer les logements,
bah les générations futures s'adapteront
et chaufferont moins leur logement et
seront pas forcément plus malheureuses
que nétaient les précédentes. Et à
l'inverse, si un certain nombre de
conditions se continuent à se dégrader,
ce qui sera le cas pour un certain
nombre de paramètres à mon avis parce
que ne serait-ce que de par le la la
question de la pression démographique
qui qui qui serait un peu cavalier de
denier parce que c'est factuel et que ça
va continuer au moins pendant un certain
temps, et ben les gens s'habitueront
aussi quoi quelque part et que
est-ce que est-ce que dans votre bouquin
vous apportez des solutions ?
Alors des solutions ? Oui, si quand
même. Enfin, j'ai pas en fait voulu
faire un j'ai pas voulu faire un HDOTC 2
avec je sais pas quoi, soit un programme
politique, soit une série de Je je
d'abord je suis pas équipé pour ça et
puis je pense que moi je préfère
inoculer le virus et puis qu'après des
voilà des gens un petit peu partout
chacun dans le leurs organisations
respectives ou leur trajet de de vie ou
leur projet peut-être puissent s'emparer
de ces de ces questionsl enfin en tout
cas puissent être éventuellement
que ça soit utile quoi à la réflexion.
C'est moi, c'est juste ça qui qui m'a
guidé. Et donc en fait, j'ai plutôt
essayé de de de sortir un certain nombre
de de principes ou de ou ou d'alerte ou
de ou de questionnement, par exemple sur
la question de [grognement] la question
de la complexité, par exemple.
Aujourd'hui, on a un monde qui est très
complexe. C'est d'ailleurs ça qui à mon
avis perturbe un petit peu le les hommes
et les femmes politiques parce que
finalement face à des décisions à
prendre, vous avez lobby numéro 1 qui
vous dit blanc, vous les écolos qui vous
disent noir ou le contraire et
finalement c'est bien difficile de
savoir ce que ça va effectivement
donner. Donc vous osez pas trop tirer
les ficelles et vous allez plutôt être
dans une logique un peu gestionnaire et
timide. C'est ça qui fait d'ailleurs que
même si on prome formidablement
l'innovation à tout va avec
l'entrepreneur néochumpetérien
formidable en fait on est hyper timide
sur plein de plein de composantes de
l'innovation à commencer par les
innovations économiques ou les les
innovations politiques. On l'a vu avec
les gilets jaunes par exemple, c'est non
changer le système politique. Non non,
attendez surtout pas. Et ça d'ailleurs
c'est très béconien Francis Bacon, un
nouvel Atlantide. Enfin dans la
philosophie béconienne, il faut faire de
l'innovation technologique.
Effectivement ça va apporter du bonheur.
Par contre faut pas faire d'innovation
il était pas pour la il était pas
révolutionnaire Francis Bacon. Il faut
pas faire d'innovation politique et pas
d'innovation économique. Ça c'est trop
dangereux, ça crée des remous, des
trucs. Donc il l'écrit explicitement,
pas dans la NouvelleAtlantide, mais dans
dans dans d'autres bouquins. Et voilà.
Donc on est un peu dans cette logique là
en fait. On promeut l'innovation
permanente, la prise de risque. En fait,
on a jamais vécu dans une société aussi
peureuse. Et je fais même le pari que on
on la plupart des gens qui promeuvent
l'innovation
euh enfin dans dis donc qui qui vont
dans le sens de l'innovation dans les
grandes entreprises par et cetera
sont les plus rétrogrades
en fait sont innovent la bayonnette dans
le dos. C'estàd que ça ça les les cadres
dans les grandes entreprises qu'on
bassine à coup de blockchain de
numérique de machin mais il y en a je
suis persuadé qu'il y en a 90 % qui qui
qui ont pas envie de faire ça. Enfin en
fait l'humain l'être humain n'est pas un
innovateur. C'est c'est une erreur en
fait de croire ça
quand même homoilis.
Et ben justement alors là c'est
bon débat. Ben oui mais alors c'est là
que ça vient intéressant en fait. Donc
quand on a il y a un facteur agressif ça
nous pousse à innover. C'est ça.
Alors non, alors évidemment quand il y a
la quand il y a de la pénurie, quand il
y a voilà quand il y a de la pression
démographique e les gars là c'est à
votre tour d'aller conquérir l'île
d'après hein parce que les mecs qui
étaient en avec qu'on traversait avec
des bateaux de bambou, il fallait avoir
un certain courage donc fallait sans
doute avoir la bayonnette dans le dos
aussi. Enfin en tout cas la sagait. Mais
non en fait ça faut le moi j'ai c'est
c'est la relecture de de Lewis Mumford
qui m'
vraiment m'a m'a beaucoup touché et plus
sur cette question là en fait.
effectivement, il y a cette espèce de de
logique un petit peu
disons téléologique presque sur le le
fait que voilà, on a le cerveau s'est
développé au fur et à mesure qu'on
allait faire des pointes de silex de
mieux en mieux tailler et puis que voilà
effectivement au mot homo abilis homopha
l'homme en fait non probablement ça a
pas ça a pas forcément fonctionné comme
ça mais aujourd'hui il on réfléchit un
peu différemment même Ford il a il a une
théorie assez attachante je trouve il
dit
En fait, le cerveau s'est développé un
peu d'un coup et ils ont failli devenir
bargeot parce que en fait, il y a une
espèce, il y a des mutations génétiques
qui fait qu'en fait voilà, il y avait
des un moment ils ont pris conscience
d'eux-même. Ils ont pris
sur l'évolution du cerveau, je crois que
c'est quand on est passé d'un aliment
cuit, ça a permis à notre système voilà
de de de reuter l'énergie sur notre
cerveau. Et donc en fait, il dit les
hommes se sont réfugiés dans la routine
et dans la procédure. Et si vous
regardez bien effectivement un certain
nombre de fondamentaux
sociologiques ou anthropologique en fait
d'abord ça va pas innover si vite que ça
c'est évidemment vous visitez un musée
de la préhistoire bon bah effectivement
ça ça va vite mais en réalité c'était
combien ? C'était un tous les j'en sais
rien 10 générations qui tapaient sur
silex un peu différemment. 9 fois sur
10, il se faisait casser le crâne parce
que le boulot de base, c'était faire la
même chose qu'avait fait papa et grand
papa ou maman et grand-maman. Et donc
les les innovateurs d'ailleurs même
jusqu'au 15e 16e siècle, ils étaient
c'était des hérétiques, hein. On devait
pas innover. Euh et euh et en fait
ensuite par contre ce que l'être humain
sait faire c'est imiter.
Alors là pour le coup quand il y en a un
qui a innové mais c'est un sur j'en sais
rien 100000 un million que sais-je alors
là les autres quand on voit que ça
marche ils vont imiter à tout vitesse et
c'est ça la force du truc [grognement]
surtout quand on imite une connerie bon
c'est juste un détail
oui mais il y a pas que bon voilà il y a
pas que il y a pas que donc alors j'arri
oui la complexité
on arrive à la fin
ouais bon
donc on peut terminer la phrase
sur la complexité non mais du coup par
exemple moi il me semble que aujourd'hui
on va vers toujours plus de complexité
on essaie de régler les problèmes avec
de la complexité la smart city c'est ça
mais en En fait, du coup, on va créer
des effets systémiques. Alors, la Smart
City, il paraît que ça serait 200 Go
octuite
par jour et par habitant de la Smart
City. Ça dépend ce qu'on met dans cette
smart city. Voilà, 200 Go, ça veut dire
qu'en 20 jours, en fait, on double tous
les 20 jours, c'est la quantité qui est
aujourd'hui stockée sur le cloud par
humain, hein, 4000 Goct. Donc ça, ça va
très vite. Et après, il faut trouver les
data center pour les construire et puis
faut donc il y a il y a ces effets un
peu déportés. Et donc il me semble que
on a ces
euh il y a des choses où il faut aller
vers la simplification, vers la
résilience. C'est que la smart city du
futur du milieu du 21e siècle qui est
basée sur des euh des entreprises
californiennes qui ont leur data center
en Islande ou en Finlande, des capteurs
qui sont fabriqués en Asie du Sud-Est
avec des matières premières issues de 50
pays différents dont dont 25 sont
instables géopolitiquement. Est-ce que
c'est vraiment la meilleure manière
d'aborder le 21e siècle, siècle des
menaces ou pas ? Enfin bon, le 20e a pas
été non plus fort folichon, mais euh
voilà et et cette question de la
résilience, cette question de la
possibilité de de voilà d'être en plus
en autonomie et donc en simplification,
il me semble que c'est quelque chose
d'intéressant. Et qu'est-ce qu'on peut
en tirer ? et ben que parfois une bonne
vieille interdiction, même si c'est un
peu écolticide, c'est sans doute
furieusement plus efficace que un marché
je sais pas quoi de de quota échangeable
ou des choses comme ça. Voilà, il y a
des questions d'échelle aussi ce que
j'ai essayé un petit peu d'aborder.
Alors moi j'ai j'aime beaucoup Olivier
que vous aviez reçu aussi sur sur cette
question de taille enfin le fait que un
moment on doit raisonner par rapport à
l'échelle. On
jamais reçu Olivier.
Non. Ah bah il faut alors ouais
d'accord. C'est un un impensé son 06. Ah
bah ouais, j'ai j'ai son 06, j'ai son
email, il y a pas de problème. Ouais.
Donc voilà, donc il a écrit entre autres
récemment sur le transhumanisme, il a
écrit auparavant il y a 5 6 ans sur une
question de taille, c'est de dire
finalement on ne peut pas faire des
raisonnements si on ne réfléchit pas à
l'échelle à laquelle on raisonne.
C'est-à-dire qu'en gros, dire par
exemple la concurrence c'est bien ou
c'est pas bien hein entre je sais pas
quoi les régime soviétique et puis
régime capitaliste. Ben ça veut rien
dire en fait. La concurrence des
boulangers, c'est sans doute très bien
parce que si je me fâche avec ma
boulangère, je peux aller en voir un
autre. Mais la concurrence dans les
centrales nucléaires, ça se discute.
Voilà. Donc c'est a une histoire de
question d'échelle. Et sur la question
d'échelle, il me semble qu'il y a des
trucs, par exemple en ce moment, il y a
un débat exactement sur ça, c'est la
question de taxe kérose. À quelle
échelle peut-on appliquer une une taxe
kérosène ? Et si oui, à quelle échelle
est-ce que c'est mondial ? Ah oui, mais
alors c'est pas possible. Les accords de
Washington. Ah mais alors les mot
européens, ah ça dépend mon bon
monsieur. Et au niveau français, oublier
c'est pas possible. Voilà, il y a des
questions d'échelle et il y a des choses
en fait dans le débat sur les mesures
écologiques ou environ environnementales
qu'on pourrait prendre, très souvent, on
tombe sur la question de la
compétitivité euh euh sur la question de
l'emploi et en fait vite on dit bah oui
mais non attendez, on va pas mettre une
taxe carbone, les emplois vont se
barrer, la chimie va s'installer au
Qatar, les poulets sont brésiliens, je
sais pas quoi. Donc il y a des
questions. Dès qu'on on arrive avec la
puissance publique qui peut arriver avec
une approche normative, réglementaire,
fiscale, très vite on dire "Aon, non,
non, c'est pas possible." Or, en
réalité, il y a des il faudrait
distinguer entre des choses qui sont
délocalisables et d'autres pas. Il y a
des choses qui ne sont pas
délocalisables par nature. Si j'interdis
à Burger d'eau et McKing par exemple
pour citer deux marques fort connues,
j'interdis l'emballage en disant au 1er
janvier 2021, allez, on va leur laisser
un an et demi
comme les sacs plastiques. Non,
j'interdis intégralement. Voilà, je je
mets en cause leur business model parce
que je dis vous allez pas pouvoir
distribuer votre junk food euh dans des
dans des emballages jetables. Quand bien
même vous me raconteriez que vous
commencez à les recycler, à les ramasser
autour des magasins. Et bien, ils ont
pas le choix. Ils vont pas venir me
livrer en drone à partir de la Belgique,
de l'Espagne et de la Suisse. Donc ils
devront s'adapter et ils devront trouver
une solution pour s'adapter. Et donc ça
c'est des quelque part des mesures qu'on
pourrait absolument prendre et quelque
part une prise de judo à cefin à ce
système capitaliste dans lequel on est
pour pour le meilleur et pour le pire en
tout cas pour l'instant et pour un
certain temps sans doute avec cette
force d'innovation. C'estàd que sous
contrainte il est effectivement capable
de s'adapter. Donc je sais pas ce que
pourrait être la solution dans la
restauration rapide pour dire
débrouillez-vous pour plus générer ces
déchets. Démerdez-vous mais je veux que
ces déchets soient gérés à la source.
Voilà. Bon, c'est des exemples comme ça.
Donc, j'en prends un certain nombre sur
euh sur le numérique, sur les data
centers, sur les voitures. Enfin,
on arrive à la fin. Est-ce que vous avez
un conseil pour les jeunes générations ?
Euh, soyez vertuux.
Soyez vertuux. Alors, pourquoi je dis ça
? Parce que voilà, la vertu. Alors, la
vertu, ça fait un peu bizarre parce que
maintenant la vertu, c'est un mot qu'on
plus qu'on emploie plus vraiment.
[grognement]
Euh la vertu, c'est un peu la vertu des
plantes médicinales ou du régime
créétoire maintenant.
Et la sagesse, c'est c'est maître de non
c'est
Oui. Non, la vertu c'est la c'est quoi ?
Bon, en gros, c'est la recherche la
recherche du bien contre le mal en
toutes circonstances. Et enfin, il me
semble que on devrait c'est peut-être un
des rares points sur lequel on pourrait
être assez d'accord avec Laurent
Alexandre parce qu'il dit va falloir
faut refaire des humanités à l'école.
Voilà, je pense qu'on doit voilà, il y a
plein de choses qu'on a déjà inventé,
qui ont déjà été écrites qu'on oublie
parce que voilà, décalage du point de
référence shifting baseline, c'est
compliqué de maintenir aussi une
connaissance suffisante dans l'ensemble
de la population. Euh
on peut voilà peut-être se rebaser sur
la sagesse des anciens. C'est d'ailleurs
le titre d'un ouvrage de Bacon aussi
pour essayer de voilà de de retrouver de
la mesure dans notre manière de
percevoir le le monde et de considérer
ce que c'est qu'une vie bonne et
réussie.
La frugalité.
Voilà la frugalité heureuse ou la
sobriété. On peut appeler ça comme on
veut.
Philippe [grognement] Wix. Merci.
Merci à vous.
[musique]